hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only grant cardone
enjoy
every business i have five companies now
we'll do a hundred million this year i
started every one of those companies
with no money zero money man just hustle
and grit and courage
i've called on people i didn't want to
be with i've done things i didn't want
to do okay it is not about doing what
you love it's about doing whatever it
takes
to make your dreams a reality to be
closed and stay closed if you're not
closed on your product if you're not
buying your own product why would you
expect anybody else to
man 400 bucks is a lot of money your
prospect says to you 400
do it
listen to me man you're 32 years old
you've been trying to save money for 20
years and you hadn't do it and do it now
i don't need anything special here i'm
not going to be empathetic
quit being stupid write to check
i don't know if the compliance guy likes
that or not
but i know this look if you believe in
what you're selling how many of you
believe in what you're selling
then close the deal
then close the deal okay learn to close
and you'll never be without work you'll
never be without money you'll have an
organization that is booming in
affluence
you'll have a pipeline full you'll have
appointments filled up
right i call it a a group called me
yesterday i'm actually trying to do a
deal with cnbc and the guy says i'm
interested i said good i'll be there
tomorrow call me back i'll be i'm flying
into new york tomorrow what am i trying
to do right now by the way i was
supposed to be here today
i'll fly into new york tomorrow i can be
there tomorrow mr ackerman okay how does
that work
i can't do tomorrow i was going to be
here anyway i'm trying to close the day
let me close the deal i'll figure out
how to be in two places at one time
later
right you some of you in the room
they're like hey i can see at four
o'clock on tuesday right and the
customer says to you i'll see you at
four o'clock
let me look at my calendar like like
you're so busy
dude that is so old
that is so old and it's dishonest
[Music]
it's dishonest man
you want to see me tuesday four o'clock
i give you tuesday at four o'clock agree
today
done
done i'll call you if something changes
if there's an earthquake between now and
next tuesday tuesday morning there's a
massive earthquake and i can't be there
you think everybody understands
commit first they're gonna rest out
later close the deal right now fill your
calendar up your calendar's got the
devil all over it
white space on a calendar and you will
meet the devil you don't need to die
okay you go two or three days without
anything going on how many of you start
having doubts
you're in hell
oh my god this ain't gonna work for me
there's nobody coming in i'm not gonna
hit my target okay i know what i'll do
i'll lower my target
that's the devil doing that man that's a
criminal
never ever if you're taking notes never
lower a target
never lower a target never lower a
target your mom and dad would tell you
to lower a target a manager might tell
you to lower target be reasonable
be reasonable with yourself
just bring it down a little bit no man
criminal products are created like that
a guy sees the girl that he wants that's
the girl
she says no he goes to another girl
right he gave up on his dream
if you're going to give up in your own
dream how are you going to build an
organization you will never
ever experience great change in your
life
unless you're willing to give up
something that you have right now
every single time in my life i have had
to give up something i wanted
i'm not talking about getting rid of the
bad stuff you got to get rid of
something that you actually worked for
to get
it might have been the house
it might have been oh my kids are in the
best schools now it's going to be
something painful for you to get to the
next place you have to give up something
that you worked for really really hard
so i sold my house one day i had this
cognition hey to get what you want you
have to give up what you have
that has been true for me throughout my
entire life i had to leave lake charles
louisiana went went to houston had to
leave houston once i got comfortable
with my community and my friends had to
leave san diego had to go to l.a l.a is
a pit
compared to la jolla nobody goes from la
jolla california up to los angeles
nobody does that you'll leave kansas
city to go to los angeles
because you want to be an actor i met
elena within five minutes of arriving in
l.a
i sold my house i sold my house i didn't
leave it vacant
as a backup plan i left this house okay
like i couldn't buy this house today if
i wanted to it was so like it was a
precious little treasure
i had to give that up by the way i had
to give up being the mayor of my little
town everybody knew me it wasn't a
restaurant i couldn't walk into i could
always get a seat i could always get the
best seat i had it right in my hand this
is what i'm telling you guys you have to
be willing to give something up and the
moment you do you better have your
partner on your side
whoever's in your life mom whoever's the
big influence that significant other
person in your life that you're going to
consult that everybody's going to
consult every one of you are going to
hey what do you think should i
you better have that person on your side
in my case i was by myself
so my consultant was like you going to
do this dog i called my buddy dale dale
you think i should he's like you're
miserable bro you got everything you
want and you're miserable
he's like what what do you have to risk
sold the house went to los angeles lived
in a hotel i went from a house on the
ocean to living in a hotel uh the hotel
room was probably like i don't know
maybe the size of this stage so please
please do whatever you got to do this
weekend to figure out whatever you got
to do to get rid of whatever is holding
you back most of which is something you
worked hard to get
okay maybe before the weekend's over you
could write down two or three or four
things you worked really hard to get
that you think you're supposed to keep
you got them already you got it you
already did that you don't have to keep
it one thing that i've done since i was
25 years old is learn how to set goals
put them in place and then manifest them
over periods of time in my lifetime if
you go back and listen to the rules of
success that i shot that show and i
think i was 4 35 years old 36 years old
in la jolla california i was living on
the ocean then and
you can go back to that you can look in
the 10x rule when i wrote the 10x rule i
shared a bunch of goals that was 11
years ago you can see over the last 25
years every single goal that i have set
for myself up to this point anyway i
have been able to achieve my wife my two
beautiful kids the condition that my
body's in today my finances the real
estate all of it started
with goals all of it started with the
idea that was in my mind and had not yet
been manifested in reality
i heard a saying once uh barbara
streisand said that there was not one
thing in her career that she had
accomplished tips on writing goals
number one write them down every day in
fact what i do is i write mine down on a
blank sheet of paper
i write them down in the am i write them
down in the pm
and i also write them down anytime i'm
disappointed or discouraged
okay so i could actually write my goals
down more than twice a day always in the
am always in the pm first thing i do in
the morning first thing i did today
was i wrote my goals down second thing
what i'll do before i go to sleep
tonight is write my goals down it could
be on the same legal pad second thing i
write them down in present tense
in pt
present tense or even past tense
or past okay so i may write it as though
i have accomplished it what you don't
want to do is
write it down
one day i will love my job okay you want
to write down i love my job even if you
hate your job right now just like flip
it i love my job okay i love my wife and
kids i didn't have a wife and kids
my kids loved me i didn't have any
children okay i wrote it down as though
it was happening okay
write your goals down
whether or not you're achieving them or
not it doesn't matter that you're
achieving them okay this is going to
sound a bit like you're deceiving
yourself which is what you're doing
you're you're writing down the future as
though it's happening today and or has
happened number four strongly suggest
that you go ten times bigger on your
goals than you think
what is accomplishable okay i say go big
or
go bigger baby
okay go big or go bigger there is
nothing wrong with big think
it doesn't cost anything okay you can't
get taxed for thinking big
and it's not just
okay i'm a dream big and big things are
going to happen okay i am going to
write down hey i'm trying to achieve x
in my life i'm trying to go from here to
10 times bigger than i can think
okay during the day i'm going to take
the actions that support that when i
write this down every day number five do
not be disappointed
in not achieving just keep writing
just because you're not hitting it just
keep writing it
i wrote down off and on from time to
time i wrote down for years my dad
worked his ass off and when he died
he did good my mom had to sell
everything
and so i'm like okay that didn't work
but he was considered successful the
middle class successful briefcase good
job professional people respected him
saved his money had life insurance house
was paid for everything by the book
and she was unloading stuff the next
week because she was terrified and so
from the age of 10 to like
16 17 years old [ __ ] we were just scared
dude clipping coupons
buying everything on sale
single mother everywhere she goes she
knows they're gonna rip her off the
plumber the roofer the car dealer
everybody's going to rip her off right
so she thought save your money save for
a rainy day yeah you know penny saved is
right a penny earned it's not it's a
penny yeah right it's a penny yeah i
mean it's a penny dude yeah you won't
even pick a penny up today you ain't
with a penny dude
yeah you know 50 cent come on man
that's 50 pennies
you know people say the dumbest things
it could be family it could be your wife
your husband it could be a a mom a dad a
uncle an aunt it could be your kids
coming from school people say what they
think and what they think will be what
they say and what they say and think
often enough long enough reinforced
enough
i promise you will be what they do okay
so look at some of the dumb things you
say like this here's one dumb thing
people say
time heals all things
really
you get a splinter in your foot and you
don't pull the splinter out you don't
look at it confront it and say i gotta
pull that little
booger out i gotta pull that little
splinter out if you just leave it there
you might get used to it yeah you'll get
used to it 30 years goes by you still
got a splinter in your foot who knows
that splinter gets into your bloodstream
goes to your heart spikes your heart
kills you time does not heal all things
folks you know what heals all things
taking a look at it having the courage
to look at it hey what happened to me
how did i screw up here what what hurt
or what pain or what happened that i had
a loss i see people go through life with
all these losses unwilling to look at
them all crippled by the time they get
older not old but they looking old
because they believe that time heals
look time heals when you confront it
when you look at it when you pull the
splinter out and take responsibility for
it don't believe everything you believe
you know what i'm saying because some of
the ideas you got they just dumb
and dumb things will cause you to do
dumb things look if you're 50 years old
and you're hearing this message right
now and you're like man how could i ever
do that i started my game when i was 51
years old
literally
i was 51 years old
i had flown 3 million miles on american
and delta
and united
and continental plumo and southwest
and northwest i flew them all
did whatever i had to do most the time i
was flying coats
most of the time i was flying coach in
order and hoping for an upgrade
sometimes i was just flying on a ward
mile
doing everything i could busting my ass
saving my money parking my doe i was
flying i don't know probably 125 000
miles a year
i barely saw elena and elena and i got
sat down one morning we didn't have any
kids yet but my right arm started to get
tired
hold on
and uh
we said hey we got to change the game
man
i'm going to destroy my life
my health
is 51 years old buying commercial
everywhere
and literally we got on the same page
came up with a plan
here we are today
i'm so proud of you yeah thank you if
you're over 50 years old and you're
hearing this message right now and you
you're not where you want to be
maybe you're married
maybe your marriage is paying a price
right now you're busting your ass man
and you're like how do i ever get ahead
you see these people on these planes
over here thank you
see these people on these planes
you're like how do they do that
look you got to figure out one or you
committed
because a lot of you just going to give
up you're going to be like like i used
to do that he'd be like this it's
impossible to ever have this impossible
so number one you got to be like hey it
is possible
if i can do it you can do it if they can
do it
if they can do it look it's possible so
first you got to say hey it's possible
for me if it's possible for them how did
you get started like what was your first
company what did it look like how did
all that happen my first company was
working for somebody else you know like
until
it wasn't until i figured out how to
make somebody else rich that i could be
be rich like
i hear a lot of guys saying i don't want
to work for somebody else i don't want
to keep making other people
when i became successful in another
company
and then left that company and went and
worked for another company and made them
super successful to the point to where
these companies were literally dependent
upon me
like that that's the thing that's the
muscle and the grit
the the uh
persistence and fortitude
are like you know what i don't my ego
wasn't like i need my name on it but my
ego was strong enough to say i want to
be the best
in the company like i want to make this
company dependent upon me the first
company the first real job i had was my
sixth job
i was fired from my first five
fired from my sixth job six times but
wouldn't leave the last one i just would
not leave so literally like
i wreck stuff i i have a terrible
driving record and i was in the car
business
and i'd wrecked their cars and and
they'd fire me and i said okay okay okay
and i had a bunch of other problems as
well but
and then before i would leave
i would go sell something and then they
would keep me on if selling something
was always forgiveness
so um
when i finally left that company they
went under like they could my production
was so high that one person leaving the
entire company failed
went to my next job which was speaking
consulting
using my sales
philosophies
and gifts if you will
and we would go around companies and
teach them
and
i worked for him for 20 months i was
like
the top guy in this company now the
reason i'm saying that is that was a job
for me and that was a business i treated
that little my little department like
this is my company within a company
and and i wanted to make that company as
strong as possible so that when i made
when i finally went out on my own
which i was forced to go out on my own i
didn't want to go out of my own i went
out on my own just because there was
just no opportunity left
and there was no way for me to score
where i was
which i i still remember today it's
important to get good people to keep
them that like you got to give them some
other
pond to swim in
and so when i started my first company
uh i guess i was 29.
um that was a company where i was
cold-calling on businesses around the us
and canada i can tell you for me like i
was always scared of money you know and
and i was terrified of it so so like if
you look at still today like i look at
the bill of everything
it's a bill of everything
if something caused something i want to
know how much it was
and so like
how much is it like i'm going to ask
that question
whether whether it matters or not um it
doesn't matter where i get in my life i
don't think i'm ever going to be free of
how much was that how much is the dinner
how much how much was dinner how much
was the tip how much was the code how
much was the jacket what did you know me
me and elena like elena's like hey it's
gonna be fine man like look what look
look look at what you've done we cannot
spend this and i'm like how much was it
i want to know how much it was because
when i grew up do you had to know what
things cost
and so the point your question about
money is it's a terrifying thing because
it's the one thing in life
that
you know the nfl is not going to give me
the ball
and and i'm never going to get a chance
to golf i can't win in those
environments but with money
everybody gets money it's the one place
where everybody gets it and now what do
i do
and i could lose it now
so it's a terrifying concept like like
power
you know very few of us ever ever get
any kind of influence or power right
once you get it you're like hey what do
i do with this
you know am i going to do it am i going
to do the right things with it and so i
think people withhold themselves because
they don't we're not educated about
money we don't know where it comes from
we have a lot of misinformation about it
our parents terrified us
you know money doesn't grow in trees
uh save your money it'll save you all
these these these things our parents
told us because they were enamored
or are encumbered
with the same kind of liabilities around
money right i don't know how to get it
i don't know how to keep it
and the
the third the worst part that we're all
at is i don't know how to invest it yeah
so what i'll do is i'll some people get
good at getting it
very few actually fewer people at
keeping it
but probably more than getting it
there's probably a big group in america
that have learned how to keep money
because they're afraid to lose it they
don't want to invest it they don't want
to use it they don't want to you know um
you know kanye talks about this how
white people how white people save all
their money and they just keep it they
just store it like i had an uncle he
buried everything he ever made he went
in the backyard wow
the other uncle was was uh he was he was
a guy that bought he he worked hard very
very frugal
italian descent
and he would uh buy real estate but it
was always buy low and sell high he
actually never sold anything but that
was the concept buy low by the cheapest
lowest get everything on a deal if
there's food stamps to be gotten you go
get those food stamps if there's a if
there's a government deal get it if it's
section 8 and the government will pay
you pay it so both these guys different
kind of mentalities were extremely
frugal
my other uncle
was uh worked in a refinery he basically
saved all his money paid everything off
got out of debt that was their lifestyle
my dad died when i was 10.
so he paid all his debt off had
everything paid and so that's all i had
right everybody around me was like get
money
keep it keep it don't use it you know
but but you should invest but nobody
ever learns that third one
and and so i think we're just a bunch of
people walking around terrified
of this
this apparent
apparency of it's scarce
right
and it's not
and and you know it's not there's
nothing scarce about it you know i'm
always keeping it real with you what has
happened to our country that we make our
idols and our icons and our heroes
rappers and entertainers and ball
players and then we show discuss
for a business man that can bank 50
million a year or 20 million a year what
is wrong look when a guy can go out and
make passive investments great decisions
execute show tremendous discipline okay
and disconcert between good investments
and bad investments and then make 20
million or 30 million bucks pay three or
four million dollars in taxes three or
four million dollars to his charities
his churches his community helps out
with groups of people
and and we have discontent for the
businessman that's out there year after
year
making great investments great decisions
showing leadership in the marketplace
look that marketplace out there that
economy is the most savage
most
difficult
playing field in the world to negotiate
yet
who do we admire in our culture
rock stars look these guys got great
skills kid gets out of school makes 12
million a first year and we make posters
of them and sweatshirts
and you put their kids in their jerseys
what about the business people that make
our economy work they pay the taxes that
make the schools work the churches work
to make the fire department the police
department because they pay taxes
because they're out there making great
investments look admire business people
they're able to bank year after year
admire these people study them learn
from them don't be disgusted with them
and turn off anybody anybody that would
suggest to you that making money in this
country is wrong look don't envy
business people admire them emulate them
learn from them particularly these guys
are doing it year after year after year
not just on income but on wealth
development because that's where you
need to be that's where you need to be
thinking that's the economy you want to
create for yourself your family your
household and your future you should be
investing in yourself
some of you got more money in wells
fargo bank of america citibank
than you do in yourself
your self-improvement
is a no-brainer okay there's no money no
nothing nothing that no book i've ever
read that somebody can take away from me
it's impossible
give me one piece of data that's good
for me
give me one experience this positive for
me no one can steal it you can't tax it
and it cannot be depreciated
see like i got no money on me right now
how many of you saw undercover
billionaire
yeah you should you should take a look
if those of you didn't see it you don't
need money to make money
okay you need people
as long as you as long as you're willing
to extrovert yourself into the community
and meet people hey how you do what's up
who are you
oh my god
like you don't even know how to do it
right you just need to be like hey
what's up everybody try this what's up
no no what's up
see people gonna be like what's wrong
with him
you should practice this this weekend
every time you go to the restroom or go
to the bar hey how you doing hey hey hey
hey how you doing hey
what's up
you know just say hi to people just get
used to extraverting yourself onto
people because people that you don't
know have everything that you want
and it's going to make you feel better
about you you got to go out and earn
money period well you don't really need
to earn it you just need to collect it
you need to get it
when you go around the money game you
got to remember this okay there is no
shortage of money on planet earth
there is no shortage of success on
planet earth there's more money than
there is people
there's more money than there are trees
there's more money than there are phones
and there's a lot of phones on this
planet there's more money than there is
tv shows like
you can't pick anything and by the way
anytime there's more of something then
there is money they just put up on money
money is printed you don't need to make
it you need to collect it
you need to collect it you need to earn
it you need to get it
so when you do your money target okay
the next thing you're going to connect
to is how do i get this money and that
will always be about the who
how to get money is about people it is
not about some idea it's not about i'm
going to create an app i'm gonna
manufacture something it's not even
about i'ma solve a problem even though
you hear that all the time it's about
how
who
who
can help me solve my how you understand
who has my money who's got my money
who's got your money who's got your
million 10 million
who's got your
kids college tuition who's got your
christmas gifts who's got your halloween
uh costume whatever the case you know
this concept of time management has been
pushed off on me my entire life and i
have never ever agreed with it i'm like
why would i want to manage time
why would i what am i going to do how do
you manage time what do i do i like okay
i'm going to watch these seconds dude i
don't want to manage time i want to
produce i want to be highly productive i
want to squeeze time i literally want to
take time and i want to turn 60 minutes
into three hours of production that's
the different thing that you need today
not manage time now there are some
tricks when managing time if that's
where you want to come from like alan
greenspan alan greenspan and his
roommate in college his roommate's
father taught alan greenspan a little
trick that alan greenspan used his whole
life and it was to break up the day into
15 minute blocks
15 minutes i have something and then
fill up the next 15 minutes now the
reason alan did that and i like that
concept a lot is because he didn't want
white space on that calendar he knew
white space was a problem because
white space nothing in the 15 minutes is
a waste of time
see before you start thinking about just
managing time first i want you to do
this number one i want you to make a
list of things that you're doing every
day that is a waste of time that is the
way you create time not manage it
the first thing i want to do is look at
things that i'm doing that are wasteful
those two or three hours a day that are
wasteful moments things i'm doing on
facebook that just a waste of time or
maybe a game i'm playing it's a waste of
time or maybe
a newspaper i'm reading where i'm not
really learning anything i'm reading
about the the celebrities it's a waste
of time okay second thing i want you to
do is this i want you to then start
thinking about these 15-minute blocks
and filling that calendar up but the
third and most important thing i want
you to think about is how can you create
time
how can you literally take 24 hours and
and pack more into it so that you can
become more productive so that you can
use that urgency concept and really blow
up your your career blow up your life
make the most incredible life for your
family for you for the kids for your
wife or your husband and for your
clients so that you can take care of
yourself materially as well 12 years ago
we had done maybe i don't know 20
million dollars over the internet
we've done over a billion dollars in
sales over the internet in the last 12
years okay
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
like you guys got to learn how to use
enthusiasm like when you use it use it
like the more you use the more you get
you like i'ma save my energy now and i
want to give him too big a hand too
early
it's really early today come on look man
with somebody successful you ought to
throw it out that's what i'm talking
about
see
you guys you guys gotta y'all got y'all
gotta quit trying little tricks and
gimmicks like if you got to walk on fire
to get excited you are ramped up
like like if you can't at will whenever
you want to for any reason just get
excited
then you got a problem okay because in
real in the real world you can't you
can't be in the middle of a meeting and
i'm trying to get her to give me like a
hundred million dollars and i'm not i'm
feeling a little depressed or bad right
now or i got my attention on my kids and
and i'm like okay
[Music]
everybody's gonna be like nah we were
gonna give you 100 until you started
pumping your chest
right you can't say hang on a second man
i got to go into a state change
like that's not real you guys understand
you have to be able to that's a gimmick
and gimmicks take time okay and gimmicks
cannot be duplicated
what can be duplicated or disciplines
and that's what you're going to be we're
going to be sharing with you over the
next three days disciplines can be
duplicated if you've seen my children
okay if you've how many of you seen
sabrina and scarlet oh yeah those are
disciplines
okay if they were in here right now they
could get on that stage and talk to you
they know how to look you and eyes they
know how to shake your hand because they
have been taught how to communicate
we spend less time on teaching them how
to count than we do communicate
connect with people okay we have them
home schooled the home school teacher
what do you want to learn you just keep
teaching them what i'm teaching them
you teach them confidence you teach
employees you teach them the ability to
communicate be dangerous not careful
okay we teach our kids how to be
dangerous
i teach my kids how to meet strangers
and greet strangers we teach our kids
that strangers have everything they want
and strangers are not dangerous
okay is there danger in the society yeah
that's what those guys are for over
there
so i'm going to put my kids an
environment where they can meet 99 of
the people and feel safe to meet them
talk to them communicate with them so i
want to make sure that my kids can walk
into an environment and have
zero concern about him her or him
and they can walk out and say hey i want
to meet you because strangers
have everything that you want
the people you don't know and haven't
met these guys these guys dressed in
their robes what do you call the robes
the condor okay i have one in my closet
by the way i love the condor i put the
condor on one time and i was like i'm a
bad bad man
dude i felt so freaking powerful it was
amazing okay i grew a beard and i'm like
now i'm a man
okay give me a camel
okay it was like it was like phenomenal
right like but but you you guys need to
have that kind of swag everywhere in
life and regardless how old you are 25
and you're like i'm too young to have
swag or 55 and now you're too old it's
not true you just need to get the
confidence the bravado not fake it you
don't need to fake it you need to you
need to get you need to get confidence
if i could get rid of this right here in
life if i could get rid of these downs
man how confident would i be
i mean like i'm going into every deal
i'm a win
and that is possible folks okay but it
starts with who knows me
because if i'm walking around this
planet and nobody knows me i'm going to
be terrified be a better guy man you
know just be a good guy and be be
you know the thing i'm proud of is i get
to be grant all the time you know i'm
actually getting to the point where i'm
like hey man i finally got to be when i
i finally
became what i wanted to be
what was that me yeah
you know that i don't have to apologize
anymore and then i quit screwing up and
i quit having to call people and say hey
man like i said i went too far you know
if i could just pull some of that back
without that drug that that psychiatrist
was trying to use right you know that if
i'm less dependent upon
aggression you know and i could i could
kind of manifest more
you know like you you talk about it let
it flow more let it flow dude let it
flow you know but
but if i could get that perfect balance
of aggression and flow that's a sweet
spot yeah it's sweet dude it's hard to
find that thing spot
you know to be that
i don't want to be i don't want to be
the little stream that drips you know i
want to be like
but i don't want to damage anybody right
i don't want to hurt anybody you know i
don't want to i don't want to be in
competition anymore mm-hmm but i also
don't want to lose the edge right you
know it's a dance dude it's a dance it's
a dance match you know like like your
girl said to me the other night she's
like she said something before she left
she's like i really get who you are
you know that and that hits me when
people say that to me most people don't
get who i am um that's beautiful you
know and then she said i really get who
you are yeah and and a lot of people
don't
yeah and and it sometimes it hurts right
because i know who i really am yeah
and
but i also know the things i'm trying to
accomplish for me you know like ryan
ryan gets who i am you know
ryan ryan never takes me on man you're
you're the best queen you're the best
he just he strokes me right right
through it and and and you know my wife
i can see my wife she gets she gets
tired of the the the pounding you know
but hey man i just you know i'm a
right-handed hitter you know or i got i
got a certain ball that i throw a
certain shot i make and yeah it's my
go-to you know and when when i get
threatened i'm going to go to that
and now if i could develop some other
set of skills
you know that would be that would be a
cool thing the thing is not to just be
positive not even to offer this no
negativity policy that i talk about the
way to avoid
uh negative and distracting people man
is to vibrate at a rate so fast
okay that you're out in front of them
once i got a speeding ticket actually
here in miami and the police officer
says
why are you speeding why are you in such
a hurry i'm like dude i'm trying to stay
away from the crazies
okay if i can just get ahead of
everybody else i'm not distracted by
anybody but guys like you
and your job is to stop me but the truth
is their job is to stop me distract me
and cause me to turn around and and stop
my mission see so i got my ticket and
moved on and went to the head of the
pack again see this is what i'm telling
you man look if you want to not be
bogged down by negative distracted
people
you need to take responsibility that
you're slowing down enough to get caught
up by this magnetic charge of
distractive and negative people do you
need to vibrate so fast that these
people are distracting other people not
you get way ahead of the crowd get so
busy
that nobody's gonna jack with you man
because you're filling up your pipeline
you're full you're busy and you don't
have this stuff sticking to you look if
you've got negative people around you if
you've got distracted people and we all
do
but if it's causing you to be distracted
and negative dude you need to vibrate
you need to fill up your pipeline you
need to explode blow up get busy
so this isn't happening to you because
you're partly responsible fill your
pipeline up what are you willing to give
up you guys got to keep assessing the
situation and not be
not be
broad stroke about it and say oh i'm not
going to be a dilite or i'm going to be
a professional i'm going to i'm not
going to no no but what are you going to
give up
there are times though again when i will
give up that agreement
see like one of the things i have on
here being right you have to give up
being right
you know you can't can't want to be be
right and be successful they don't even
go together
it's impossible so again i'm willing to
give the up being right just gotta don't
quit man if you don't quit if you don't
quit you can't fail
it's impossible failure becomes
impossible for those who don't quit
it's impossible just think about it if i
keep moving towards the destination
if i if i'm if i'm going through the
alphabet
a b c d e dude if you just keep going
all the way to z you finish the alphabet
you break your leg along the way
somebody cuts your tongue out you get
waterboarded
you get a divorce you lose your dad you
lose a puppy
if you get the z you finish the alphabet
period and boy when i heard that i'm
like goddamn what was i thinking i was
thinking i could fail i can't fail if i
don't quit
so so that means i got to get rid i got
to dump people out of the car though
along the way right but we had to get
rid of a whole bunch of people
i i have to get rid of people how many
people have been have gone johnny
hun i mean guys like if you saw the
wreckage
like
so much you don't see it you know oh i'm
not saying get rid of people i'm just
saying like like like what are you
willing to give up
okay on my list i've given up a house
i've given up money i gave up my
retirement accounts i had millions of
dollars sitting in retirement accounts i
paid the penalty to get the money
because it was a mistake years ago i got
convinced by the banks to build an ira
or a 401k because i was trying to figure
out how to exit actually the people that
were giving me the advice were telling
me to figure out how to exit
you're planning an exit when you're 30
and it's stupid
think about what you're doing you're not
going to retire until you're 70
and the rich people never
worry about their retirement accounts
warren buffett has not got a 401k
he's got coca-cola
see the difference see the difference in
the think
okay so so like like you you guys have
to take a look at what you know
that is now a liability
what you know to be true
that has become a liability for you
if you just study the middle class of
america study the entire structure of
the american economy
you will see
you will see where a lot of these
liabilities exist that that are or are
core values that you have
not just for you but for the entire
population of people
and and like if you just look at the
structure of america 311 million people
most of them are not doing well
you hear about it every day so the
solution is let's give everybody college
you know
let's give everybody well college could
be one of the problems
look
you know let's make sure everybody gets
through high school okay
could be one of the problems actually
then it takes 12 years to learn how to
count
[Music]
and still no product
really
so anyway i'm not saying i'm not worried
about trying to change all that i'm just
saying you might want to look at how
some of that has influenced you
you know the retirement accounts the
life insurance how many of you got life
insurance
how many of you got some cash value
sitting there somehow
dude get the money don't wait till you
that the third thing i would say about
wealthy people is there
i mean different people have different
ways they invest but they tend to be
more
focused on the long-term appreciation of
an asset
rather than give me money this second
and and i think to get there they're not
stuck in this get rich quick thing it's
a delayed gratification yeah they're
more like yeah i'd rather have wealth
tomorrow than rich today
and they do have a distinction between
the rich and the wealthy that you know
the super wealthy are looking to create
wealth beyond
their own
means and needs like they're not
thinking about their kids their boat
their plane i know people think that but
that's not actually true they're
actually thinking about how do i create
wealth for a lot of people amazon's got
a million employees
yeah now most of them only earn minimum
wage but there are some people at the
upper level of amazon that are making
fortunes success is vital i absolutely
you maybe you've heard me say this
before it's worth writing down again
success is your duty it is your
obligation and your responsibility
success to me is as vital to my survival
as oxygen food and water
shelter i got to have shelter i got to
have water i have to have oxygen i need
food okay i need love in my life okay i
need people i need human interaction and
i also need to win if you don't have
success in your life you will lose
discipline you will lose activity you
will lose contact and you will not be
consistent you will not have them this
is the vital part of success this is why
i'm pounding to you the only trick in
this universe if there is a trick at all
is you must be successful success is not
an option it is your duty it is your
obligation it is your responsibility
2022 if it's going to be good for you
and your family
if it's going to be great for you and
your family it is because you demand
success this year
and that means you demand success in
your relationships and your finances and
in your money uh your money and in your
business your business has got to grow
for your finances to grow the reason the
guys on wall street and the gals on wall
street make so much money
okay it's not because they're they're
they're like capitalists and they're
terrible people it's because they're
surrounded by people that are making
money man they're accountable by their
stock price they're accountable to their
production they got people around them
that expect them to win and do well and
also they're going to dinner waking up
at breakfast working out in the gym with
other people that are winning big in
life okay so you need feedback from your
environment and your network fourth
thing you need is you got to have fifth
thing you need is you got to have a
network of people that are encouraging
you
to kill it you got to have the right net
you got to have a lebron in your game
man if you're playing in the nba and
lebron's like i'm going to take you
under my wing bro
okay kobe is like hey man i wanna i'm
coming back to be with you man what
would you deny that okay michael jordan
i want to be with you man tiger woods i
want to golf with you come on guys what
are you doing you cannot do this alone
you cannot do this alone are you kidding
me man let's say you want to be a
surgeon and and a top surgeon in the
world is like i want to take you under
my wing what are you going to be i i'm
too busy
if you're reading a book
okay you're listening to music
going to an event
uh
speaking at an event
let's say you're speaking in events is
the 700th time you did that presentation
you got to show up new again
johnny comes to work with his camera
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new
you got to show up every day new folks
you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new
every day you're new or
guess what you're old
[Music]
nobody wants old
i don't want to get old
i don't want stale
i don't want yesterdays
i don't want leftovers
i don't i don't i know i know when
somebody's repeating something wrote
they're just giving me the same
i don't mind some [ __ ] but it's got
to be fresh
i need some fresh [ __ ]
so i don't i don't mind a little bit
i just don't want the same thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand thousand times not in a good
way either last thing i'm gonna tell you
is this
okay
don't
get
stuck in mechanics
when i'm writing my goals down i do not
know how i'm going to do it
so i merely sit down like i remember for
years i would write down i own a
helicopter i don't even know where this
concept came from i own a helicopter i
own a helicopter i own a helicopter
every once in a while it would show up
it would show up on a wednesday and not
show up for uh when i'm writing my goals
down right so i'm waking up in the
morning i wake up in the morning and i
write my goals down and one day i write
i own a helicopter
i think back then it was i learned how
to fly a helicopter
okay it was stupid it was completely
ridiculous i'm like where'd that come
from
it just kind of floated into my mind i
wrote it down okay i own a jet
i'm like man i'm just being stupid right
now i own a jet and two helicopters
i don't know how that happened i didn't
i didn't know anything about jets uh i
would not achieve any of this by the way
until i was
53 years old 54 years old
the first private jet i was ever on was
the one
we bought
i didn't know anything about it i didn't
know how they fly i didn't know how they
work i didn't know what the cost of a
hangar was i know nothing don't get lost
in the mechanics i didn't know the fuel
cost i didn't know what it cost to buy
one do you finance them do you pay cash
do you get a tax rate i knew nothing
when i started writing this down the
helicopter would come after the jet okay
i bought a helicopter i didn't know why
so the point of that story is when
you're writing your goals down literally
sit down with a blank sheet of paper
first thing you wake up in the morning
and you just start zip zip zip zip you
right through them like this morning i
wrote down 40 billion in real estate
okay public i write down one word i'm
going public
see i know now that this this is in
present tense and or past tense i write
it in present or past tense i'm going
public okay i wrote down recently uh a
congressional hearing
people like what's the congressional
hearing dude i'm so big now they called
me into congress
they're gonna have a congressional
hearing they're gonna drill me okay oh
yeah then i wrote this down a political
office
now i don't know why
i don't know why i'm writing that down i
don't know how to achieve that i don't
know what it would mean i don't know
what it looks like i don't get stuck in
the mechanics don't worry about it
commit first man just keep committing it
keep fueling and keep writing it down 8
billion people
know my name the third thing the super
successful do is they master income
creation i was asked this morning i left
my home at four o'clock in the morning i
was on a plane at five okay and a guy
asked me he's like dude why are you
still cranking so hard
because i don't have any money i'm
always broke
i reinvest all the money every time i
get any money sitting in accounts i take
it and invest it in hard assets
illiquid assets
illiquid so that i cannot get that money
that's what keeps me motivated folks
i get money liquid money
if it's not used what
it's useless
take it and i buy a hard asset
that produces income
i'm broke i got to go hustle again i
want to share with you the uh not so
secret way that thousands tens of
thousands actually millions
of people are becoming millionaires in
america they invest in assets that
appreciate over time
they invest in assets
in ips that they control
royalties they control
things that they know over time will
increase in value
that there's a 99
99.9 chance that they're going to
increase in value and that's what they
invest in
they don't make little bets they make
big bets and they invest in things that
they know will go up in value over time
that could be a sports team
uh chances you buying a sports team are
next to none same for me
so you got to start thinking about okay
what assets can i do that with okay oh
wow i'm going to go create i'm going to
go create the next big thing
i'm going to create an app and
hundreds of millions of people are going
to download my app okay chance are you
doing that
your chances are bigger than mine
because i'm not even trying
there are assets out there today that
are in your backyard if they're in your
neighborhood you don't have to buy a
sports team you don't need to be
connected you don't have to have a you
don't have to know how to write code or
do tech
it's sitting there waiting for you right
now
and it's one of the ways that i created
the wealth that i have in my life i have
we have 11 businesses today
uh and and then we have a real estate
portfolio of 12 000 units going to 40
000 units
and uh about four billion dollars worth
of real estate now
the first the eleven businesses that i
own man they were so hard
to create them start them manage them
guide them hire people for them
advertise market get them known
like to organize it we have hundreds and
hundreds of employees in these companies
about 700 employees across these
companies most of which are startups
they're brand new they don't have a lot
of employees a lot of risk a lot of
downside a lot of problems a lot of
headaches a lot of people the real
estate
almost no headaches
compared to the value of the portfolio
very few people work at it
it appreciates the value over long
periods of time and that's what wealthy
people do they invest in assets real
estate is one of the things they love
the first three years i was in business
i made thirty thousand dollars a year
three years first three years the first
the the last year i left somebody i was
making 150 160 grand a year
the first maybe 27 months that i was in
business i made less than 30 000 a year
i went backwards
but the the problem was i was not i do
what a lot of entrepreneurs do
the mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make
is number one they never look up the
definition entrepreneur
an entrepreneur means someone is who
organizes a business or businesses and
invests money takes greater than normal
risk with money in order to expand or
organize those businesses
i wasn't spending money on my business
like all i was doing was knocking on
doors it was just pure effort i wasn't
spending money like
i wouldn't spend real money until i was
uh 50 50 years old
about 10 years ago
when when a guy said bro you're not a
business
and i said what he and i could feel this
yeah i was a hustler i was a grinder
but i wasn't a business and i and i
could feel it you know
um yeah i was a consultant i could i was
making some money like in my 30s and 40s
i made you know i made a lot of money
what other people would call a lot of
money yeah but i was not a business you
know what i mean i was just what do you
mean by that well i was just hustling
training just because you're hustling
everything was a transaction yeah
everything everything was a transaction
to get money pay the taxes have a little
bit of money left over everything was in
the transaction
and um
and this guy's like well you know you're
not a business
and i was like i know man i know don't
tell anybody i know that okay like i
knew it
and because because to me a business is
i can walk away from it'll still operate
i was i was a guy i was no different
than when i was 30 just pounding doors
and which was good which was good and i
think a lot of people need to you don't
need to skip that spot either
because once i put the two together okay
i can pound the door i can learn
e-commerce
um i can be i can be a one-product sale
i could sell to companies like today
we'll sell we'll sell a product to a
company for
80 grand on a on a three to five year
contract 80 grand a year
and i'll switch immediately and sell an
eight dollar product online or i'll give
something away for free
to speaking to 4 000 people today in
hopes that i can meet
you know maybe 40 of them that i can do
have a partnership and a collaboration
with
in the future they invest in assets of
cash flow
give me a drip
let me rip
give me a little drip
give me something every month give me
something every quarter give me
something to reward me three percent
four percent ten percent give me
something to reward me to have a 10x big
bang at the end of the appreciation of
the asset warren buffett says three
rules don't lose money two don't
remember number one don't lose money and
number three only invest in things that
cash flow you know warren buffett
he's got he's a major player in uh at
apple now and it took him forever to get
there
and the reason he finally invested in
apple was because he understood finally
understood the cash flow
of the itunes account
it was crazy that's when he made this
big move
every company he's ever invested in had
positive cash flow
and cash flow enough that they could
distribute cash flow we got to look at
your vehicle what vehicle are you in
right now
do you have any recurring revenue
do you have any opportunities outside of
what's going on right now
what are your assets and liabilities if
you're over 50 years old you're just
trying to figure out man what am i going
to do because look time is critical now
you don't have a lot of time you know
that better than i do you got to figure
this game out okay if you're committed
number one number
two we got to look at the vehicle you're
in we've got to look at do you have any
other additional income or recurring
income or repetitive income
passive income
opportunities there's so many that exist
in the world today if you don't
understand youtube linkedin instagram
all these things like i didn't
understand any of this when i was 51
years old i had no idea how to market
myself i've never branded myself i'd
never done video like this before i
didn't know if i did a video what i was
supposed to do the video on i did not
have a product lineup i was in one tiny
uh vertical
uh i heard somebody say once the the
riches are in the niches and my niche
was so tight
i wasn't right i was wrong
because i was dependent upon
this many people
i had to serve them satisfy them kneel
down to them and kiss the ring every day
and i got tired
if you're tired of kneeling down kissing
the ring
begging
putting up with bull customers
you're 50 years old you're over 50 years
old and you're like okay i got to get
recurring revenue
i got to get something that's
indestructible
i got to figure out how to do this
without spending a bunch of money i
can't disrupt my main flow right now you
got a job right now you can't walk away
from it i get it
but you're running out of time
okay you got what 10 years 15 years 20
years you want to start enjoying some of
the money some of the production it is
beyond my imagination i imagine you
can't even imagine flying private
it's beyond my imagination that i'll i'm
getting rid of a plane
and picking up another one
so if i can do this i'm telling you guys
you can do this every time you see a
private plane or a yacht or somebody
living the life just remember
if they can do it you can do it as long
as you're committed to if you find the
right vehicle just because you work hard
does not mean you'll get it you have to
find the right vehicle if you're in the
wrong vehicle you're in the wrong
vehicle doesn't mean you need to quit
your job right now it does mean you we
need to figure out what the right
vehicle is and because of the internet
because the access to the internet today
anybody regardless of where you live can
figure out how to do this 80 maybe 90
maybe 95 without being a doomsdayer
95 of the people in the united states of
america wealthiest country on the planet
are suffering
no money
no freedom no choices
can't leave their job
tied down
and they most of those 95
most of them some of them are earning
big wages 250 grand 80 grand 90 grand
maybe you're in this group 60 grand 58
000
eight thousand hundred and twelve
thousand whatever number you're earning
if you look at the the the money left
over at the end of the year into the
month or end of the the week
there's not a lot of money left over
seventy six percent of americans are
living paycheck to paycheck 55 of
americans have no money in a savings
account okay
90 of all the wealth in this country is
owned by about less than 10 percent of
all the people in this country listen to
what i just said
you and i have been doing something
wrong
we are using information that is
outdated and no longer efficient for the
kind of economy we're in today got all
kind of disruption going on you've got
to start thinking different about saving
money investing money real estate crypto
and how you how you uh do do you go over
many many investments or do you go hard
on one
we need to look at what you have been
taught about money that may be holding
you back that may not be the thing you
need to be doing any longer i'm here in
las vegas right now you know when you
walk in these casinos
almost everybody knows how to play
blackjack
almost everybody knows how to play the
little games here they even have books
how to play the games
uh the guy gets a six
he's got a 16 and the dealer's got a six
he's like i'm not going to hit that card
and he sits there and he gets beat all
night because he's playing by the book i
figured out
two things
i figured out oh [ __ ]
excuse the language
i've been doing everything wrong and
thought it was right i was doing exactly
what the book said
save your money invest in mutual funds
plan for retirement buy some life
insurance
um what was the other one work hard
oh yeah you got to work hard and you do
by the way
that's not a myth but i know a lot of
people that are working on it that end
up with nothing
like my parents my dad worked hard he
died at 52 years old
heart blew up in his chest from stress
and overwork
[Music]
probably for not taking care of himself
enough because he was out there grinding
just pounding pounding every day because
he wanted to do one thing take care of
his family
probably same thing you want to do then
my mom was left to raise five kids
and
only had a little bucket of money
sitting over there in a savings account
so she's clipping coupons terrified to
spend anything scared of them if the
plumbing breaks scared if the roofer
comes over scared terrified every day to
spend one penny
because she knew she was depleting the
account that would take care of the
family
look if you're experiencing any of these
same things today don't feel bad about
yourself like you're not you're not
like oh what's wrong with me
what's wrong with you is you have the
wrong information
you got the wrong information it's not
because you're lazy it's not because
you're stupid it's because you have the
wrong data you need to unlearn some
you need to unlearn some stuff that mom
and daddy and your teacher told you your
mentor your last guy whoever you're
listening to
if what you have now hasn't got you
where you want to go what you have now
in your head might be keeping you from
where you want to go i started studying
super successful people
not mediocre successful people
super successful people because prior to
this i had been studying anyone that had
any level of success
now i grew up in the middle class how
many grew up in the middle class
good i grew up where we had bicycles
my mom had a car we had gasoline in the
car we had food i had i was fed three
meals a day my dad died when i was 10
years old my mother was there to take
care of me i came from a really good
household okay there was plenty of love
there was a lot of nurturing
there was plenty of food there was
something in the refrigerator at all
times there was some guidance you
understand what i'm saying
so the first thing i did was i started
studying successful people and i
discovered something at 25 years old
when my life when my life and my
business weren't working well
that that that super successful people
was they they used a different way to
build their business than i was using i
was stuck mostly
in a sales cycle
from the age of 25 when i started my
first company at 29 actually till the
age of 45 for those 20 years i was stuck
in a sales cycle
and what i studied about super
successful people is they spent a lot of
money
a lot of money marketing and advertising
okay
now my mom was telling me not to do this
my brothers my sisters the people
surrounding me the people i work with
were not spending money on marketing and
advertising the second thing the wealthy
do the millionaires the self-paid
millionaires do is they play get rich
for sure i don't know if you've ever
heard this term
i coined this phrase years ago i'm not
interested in get rich quick i got some
buddies that try to teach those courses
cringe when i hear them i don't want to
get rich quick i want to get rich for
sure i've always wanted to get rich for
sure i'd like i just don't i don't
really care how long it takes as long as
i'm not old and dead but i want to know
that i'm getting rich for sure i'm not
i'm not a shark cut guy
i'm not a gambler
i'm not i'm not the guy that's gonna
throw put it all on one um one color i'm
extremely extremely conservative when it
comes to investing
uh because
i don't wanna lose my money
my parents both my parents came up
through a time when
um my mother was in food lines
and and she told me that story so many
times dude
you know i got scared that one day i'd
be in a food line so um i don't want to
get rich quick because i know that comes
with the pain of busting out okay and
that might by the way keep me from being
one of the wealthiest people in the
world because i don't
take these big chances
but if this if this is you like you're
thinking yeah i don't wanna i don't
wanna i don't wanna i don't need the
three week
uh thousand x return i wanna be able to
invest my money in something i get the
tax write-offs i get the benefits i get
the cash flow
uh i get the long-term appreciation and
that's what the wealthy do but but in
masses they don't they're not taking
um these crazy crazy chances
[Music]
everybody can do more you know and you
don't know what you can do until you see
other people doing big stuff and and
that's why today like we started this
talking about
in the past i'd look up to people want
to pull them down now i'm like wow dude
that's an inspiration yeah and i look
for people like all the way back to
jesus is an inspiration to me like
he left his town
you know i've used that jesus analogy
him leaving bethlehem did he leave
bethlehem or nazareth
now there was
some something right so i'm like you
know what nobody would know him if he
didn't leave home i've i've moved from
lake charles to houston houston to san
diego san diego to la la to miami i
might move again every move has been
good for me
so you got to leave your home you got to
leave your comfort you know you got to
walk the path and you got to get a team
yeah you need you can't do anything
great by yourself
and uh
and i truly believe all of us no matter
where you are today you can do everybody
can do 10 times more than you think you
can
and before you get to 10x you'll end up
changing the goal to 10 times more if i
had one thing to do over again i would
be like i would learn communication
skills speaking skills
debating skills i should have taken a
debating class
because i really don't know how to
debate i just make people wrong
you know
so
that's not debating but i get away with
it somehow you know
uh but but it doesn't work for most
people so people should i would
definitely go back at 18 back to your
first question i would go back and take
debating classes
i would take uh communication classes
i'd probably learn how to code
i would definitely learn how
how these guys are creating funds
spax
is a new thing
um
hedge funds
i would learn how to write do surveys
and find out hey what is it people
actually want
and i would learn how to read about
money flows and and and people flows in
the internet and algorithms and all this
fascinating stuff but i would i would
only do it for one reason by the way
just so everybody's clear
okay i would only do it so i can make a
lot of money what's the number one thing
people should do if they want to double
their income so moving on to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh you should
say almost get good at something get
good at something you know get good at
something
now
you got you got to get good at something
you got to ask yourself if you're in the
right vehicle you're an engineer you
always say that yeah the vehicle right
so so let's say you're a photographer
yeah okay because i know a guy right now
he's a photographer and he's like i want
to make more money okay we're good so
he's going to have to
he can only get so good as a
photographer
like he's a ceiling on the income isn't
it exactly like you're going to have to
go shoot a movie dude like everybody's
got a ceiling where you you finally get
to a price and they're like okay i'm
done nobody's going to buy from you so
now what are you going to do to to get
your deal you got to go sell something
you're going to have to sell some
product or some service
if you don't like to sell it then you
need to promote it so people buy it from
you so they just come buy it from you
okay so if you don't like sales then you
need to spend a bunch of money promoting
so that people oh thank you champ thank
you you need to promote it man this
looks good
see she broke
she brought me that so how do you get
somebody to bring you something right
well
you either get up and spend your own
time to go get it or you get people
around you little people around you that
you pay
ten dollars
make it five make it five she just
earned some money they know how their
money would be right they earned money
look i didn't know what else to do there
was no social media when i was 30 years
old
so
today if it's social media i'm like okay
what am i gonna do i need to find if i
want to if i want to make sales is
income i want i want income i want
income i need money right a kid a kid 18
year old kid today says i want to know
how to make passive income
he wants to stay home and earn money i'm
like dude you're skipping the step you
got to earn money first number one you
got to earn money you got to earn it or
connect with it
so i got to either get you to give me
money i don't know how many times you do
that yeah before you be like okay what
do i get okay
then number two i need to keep that
money figure out okay how do i get that
money
to do something now okay now a lot of
people know number one and and a handful
of people know how to do number two they
get the money but then they don't know
what to do with the money you got to get
the money to have babies big tip
for the wealthy that's the not so secret
secret
uh they invest in assets that give them
massive tax benefits using debt
okay number five is the game changer it
is the mack daddy wealth builder
that i did not learn until i was about
50 years old you can use debt
to give you tax benefits
and then leverage that into a asset
class in your backyard where you live
without creating anything
uh to create tremendous amounts of value
for yourself your family and your
household the wealthy the super wealthy
know that they have to use good debt
to create massive tax benefits
so they actually get 100 of the money
out of their assets
without paying any taxes this is a super
tax loophole that the wealthy have been
using for years if you want to grow your
business learn to follow up
follow up follow up
[Music]
way more than you ever imagined follow
up
i'm talking 12 follow-up calls or 25
follow-up calls
i'm talking calling somebody every month
or even twice a month long after they
weren't interested you would keep
following up do you have a good product
do you have a product people need
do you have a service people need
do you have a good company yes then
learn to follow up nobody taught you
guys how to follow up in fact you were
taught not to
what were you taught
don't bother people
you don't bother anybody don't pester
people right or wrong
okay
you don't want to nag people you don't
want to beg for the business
but what happens in most cases people
just don't they look like they don't
care because they don't follow
yo we're rolling out of cabo with family
and friends
we got elena the two girls growing up we
got jared and sandy back there
this is our last flight
on
our
gulfstream 550
man that plane has been so good to us
wow sabrina we did how many what we do
20 countries 19 countries
in
this bird back here
so good to us
it's getting ready to go home it's going
to go home
and it's going to a new owner who knows
what we get next time what do y'all
think i should hook up with because we
need something you know we're gonna
we're about to do a lot of traveling
london we're coming to you all uk
all the places we haven't been to yet
we're coming to you middle east we are
coming to you
jared has got me on a schedule
it's so strict
okay we haven't done anything in egypt
all of south america oh my god dude
elena's been practicing spanish 450 days
she's been on it already
uh doing your duolingo right elena 112
412 day c and now all she knows is that
one
so uh
yeah so we're looking forward to coming
to see australia we're coming back
thailand we're coming malaysia we're
coming back where else are we going
singapore oh for sure singapore
we have not been to india yet we gotta
come to india so look we're gonna
probably have to get something a little
bigger than th
than the beast okay i actually never
called it the beast because i didn't
feel good about calling it the beast
because i knew whoa what is that
that's uh that's that's the base right
there eight that's eight right there
that's 650 right there right yeah
and maybe one day i can own a 650.
i think that's got a titan that's an
italian point
who's xa no that must be mexico
so uh god these things are beautiful
if you've ever wondered because i know i
did
if you've ever wondered how do people
what do they do to fly these planes look
at this
i'm right underneath one of these beasts
right now
this is uh i think this is this
this is a 450 right here called stream
450. look at that you know a family owns
that plane and they fly themselves
probably from la or san francisco down
to mexico
in cabo
and then you know
family owns that plane too now the only
asset class that will protect you during
hyperinflation there's a couple of them
but there's only one that cash flows
gold certainly silver
yes
other other asset classes
that appreciate in value will get
accelerated
real estate however for the last couple
thousand years without exaggeration has
been the
the number one
the number one buy a long shot
asset class that will protect you and
your family against inflation this is
something you guys really need to worry
about uh the politicians are talking
about inflation being a problem for the
upper class look inflation
in fact uh infects
uh like a virus
everyone okay inflation warren buffett
said inflation was like the invisible
tax
if you don't like taxes you're going to
hate inflation we have not had inflation
in this country in probably
80s since the 80s like so that's uh
you know
over half of my lifetime we have not had
hyperinflation particularly
hyperinflation where you're starting to
get escalated rates of
food water prices uh gasoline prices
fuel prices diesel prices
look at home prices just in miami i'm in
miami this morning
going to this event beautiful miami
these prices in the first 10 months of
2021 these prices went up 19
that is hyper inflation that means your
mortgage payment will go up almost 20
percent
that means your down payment will go up
uh if it's a
if it's a million dollar house or 400
000 house let's say it's a 400 000 house
and you had to put forty thousand
dollars down
uh just
january of last year that down payment
now is fifty thousand dollars
so you gotta get ready for this now how
do you protect yourself one you gotta be
aware of what inflation is number two
you gotta know if i have money that's
going down in value as assets go up it
takes more money now
this bag of money this bag of money will
not basically this was a hundred
thousand dollars in this bag and because
of the inflation in the last 12 months
this is now i just basically took this
much out of it you understand that's how
inflation works the bag was full
and now the bag is less full okay
because of inflation it's invisible but
it works in reverse meaning i just
simply need more of a bag i probably
need this bag and another 20 percent of
this bag to buy the same products and
services because of the printing of
currency and because of inflation it's
not very complicated and you don't need
to figure it out you just need to know
number one it's here number two i'm
gonna do something about it you need to
do something about it and the thing that
you can do about it is not a new thing
by the way folks this is not this is not
a bitcoin this is not bitcloud this is
not nfts nfts ethereums this is nothing
this is not the the medical metaverse
this is nothing to learn like this is
simply i'm going to find an asset that
cash flows
a real property that cash flows where i
protect my capital bigger is not better
i remember a guy named phil told me this
he went bankrupt and then he says i just
want to remind you man bigger is not
better i had the bowling alley i had the
big house i had to die and i
and he's like bigger is not better man
and i believed it i bought it and so i
stayed small
um and
later i realized that
today i know bigger is definitely better
okay and and you just got to keep
getting bigger the problem with bigger
is you can't get out of the game
and you keep getting bigger and bigger
right you want to keep getting bigger
and bigger and it keeps bringing on you
can't get out of the game because then
you have obligations to other people now
there's a lot of employees but bigger is
more fun
and it comes with more problems but it
comes with more fun too i will never
give the bank money until i invest in my
business
i'm never going to save money at wells
fargo cash is trash folks how many were
taught you were brought up cash is king
it's garbage
it's pieces of paper if you saw the
stock if you saw
the dollar as a stock
in the last 55 years it's going down
like this the graph is straight down
almost a 90 depreciation value you would
never invest in that stock but what do
you guys do work your ass off trade time
for money take the money and save it so
it gets depreciated what does the bank
do as soon as you give it to them
they call me up hey mr cardone
can we lend you some of these people's
money their work hard-working people
they were working their asses off on the
weekends trading time for money and they
came and gave us the money it's amazing
these people do this over and over again
i'm like please send it over once you
and your business are doing well by the
way you'll know
it's not even a question if you're
calling me up like when should i start
investing grant
if you're still asking that question you
don't have enough money
it will be so obvious to you your
business is on banging it's banging 12
cylinders just banging man listings
coming in sales being made people
talking about you your freaking numbers
are going like this everything's like
straight up and vertical then you should
invest in something where you cannot
lose your money what should you do with
your money well well
like saving money in a bank account is
ridiculous the only people that benefit
is the bank
so what do you do with the money then
you you you use money first thing people
should invest in is themselves
like you know best thing is people hear
that and they go what does that mean
though what do i do with the money go to
go to workshops go to seminars go to
whatever you're good at whatever you're
doing you're an astronaut invest in
yourself if you're an athlete investing
yourself
don't spend money on belts
yeah and looking good like invest in
your craft you're a comedian invest in
your craft and that means investing in
your skills uh uh
whatever whatever podcast yeah whatever
needs to get you known right right and
then also in in your branding and your
marketing like people have to know you
no matter how good you are if i don't
know you it doesn't matter right so you
got to get out there yeah how did you
guys run into me how'd i run into you
yeah how'd you find out about instagram
good i invested a lot of money making
sure that people see that instagram
account right right our energy money and
energy right so
invest in yourself first
to become great at whatever you're doing
number two start investing in your
business
if that if you hadn't done that already
and the third thing is start investing
in things that will pay you every month
so you bought you buy a flow of income
this idea that it takes money to make
money is not true it's a myth it's it's
it's the number one reason why i did the
show the discovery show to debunk that
on tv
that i didn't need any money at all uh
they they offered me a hundred bucks i'm
like just keep it dude like no no we got
to give it to you it's part of the show
and i'm like i don't need the hundred
they're like no but you got to take the
hundred as part of the show the entire
90 days
i never touched the first hundred they
gave me
and this was to prove to people do you
do not need money like it's just it's
not true you need money you do need
contacts
you need people you need people you need
people you need the right people though
the right people that are already in
play
okay just because the guy's got money
i remember a billionaire friend of mine
uh you know he could buy a jet
and i said hey bob should i buy a jet he
said you should i shouldn't
meaning grant should because and he's
way wealthier than i am he could have
bought 40 of them he's like i don't have
a place to go on mine you have a you
could use yours every day
so you you got to find somebody that's
in place somebody that not just has
money but somebody that wants to do more
with their money
so you'll notice in the first uh 10 days
i don't spend a hun any money i don't
spend money on shelter not on food and
not on water
nothing then what i do is i end up
accumulating assets
and it's unfortunate that the viewer
doesn't see this within five days i have
two vehicles one was given to me by the
discovery and the other one was a 40 000
jeep
that i basically used
uh from ryan this guy i met
and told him i'm gonna sell your jeep
i'm gonna drive it around town and put
ten miles a day on it and i'm gonna sell
it well that's a forty three thousand
dollar asset
uh my truck was worth four grand i still
had my hundred dollars i lived in a
forty six thousand dollar rv that i was
trying to sell
so yeah uh and what what's the other
thing i did and i picked up ten thousand
dollars
to do in a 15 partnership in the equity
of the upside of this guy's company so
literally in 10 days
i was accumulating contacts that could
get me equity and the important part of
that story is man go get you some equity
you know jay-z talks about this you're
getting you know so many of you young
brothers are getting in advance while
i'm picking up the equity showing up
means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand doesn't mean you came to
work
[Music]
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off
i was acting a fool
being a fool
high school i didn't show up i went to
class i never showed up my body went in
the room
see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there and
then you showed up again and then you
showed up again and you showed up again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test you freaking get a
perfect grade means you keep showing up
to the next level and i hear a lot of
people talking about showing up you know
showing up's not everything let me tell
you something showing up when you show
up the right way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way
when you show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success it keeps
showing up showing up means you're
looking for deeper levels to show up to
pay attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem show up for
every little opportunity show up for
every little little nuance
little angle little particle little
movement that's why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what's it why don't
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here
hey you feeling all right today how many
times have i asked you that before you
all right today i know it's little
things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up it costs you nothing
and it makes all the difference man
showing up
you'll see things that no one else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just got to make
a commitment to show up the number one
thing is you got to make a decision
before you even take a step what is it
you want
with wealth is it to just get by
simply pay the bills you want to become
a millionaire a deca millionaire a
hectic millionaire a billionaire which
one you want to do i've done every one
of those
and i started with one thing the dream
what was the dream for me in the middle
in the very beginning was simply now i
just want to pay my bills and that was a
mistake because i was thinking too small
so
however high you set your goals and your
targets is going to determine where you
get so most importantly just set a
number is it a million 10 million 100
million a billion dollars i'm greedy and
i am i am i am very highly interested in
my personal self-improvement because i
know that's where it all starts i have
to i have to make me the most important
thing in my life
because other people can't get better if
i don't i would love to improve my
communication skills clubhouses like the
amount of eloquence the amount of people
there that are able to see other
people's viewpoints
has been fascinating to me
so number one i'd like to become a
better communicator
number two and i think i already am just
from being on clubhouse like
clubhouse has been an
incredible gift to me
yeah it's been fun it's been fun to be
in those rooms with you yeah and so i've
learned a lot about how to talk how to
listen
uh that i didn't know because of the
two-way communication you don't get that
from from facebook
and instagram yeah i don't get it from
dropping a video on youtube
uh number two is the collaboration i
want to collaborate with more people uh
number three third thing i want to do uh
you know i mean i need to work on my
relationships my my personal
relationships uh
could be a better husband definitely a
better husband i've been go i've been
running really fast i wouldn't push him
i mean i don't push my kids
i'm pushing me
so if my kids can learn from me pushing
me
because i don't want anybody pushing me
you're never going to push me as hard as
i'll push me you know i had a manager
when i was 29 28 years old he set a
quota for me and i started laughing at
him and he's like what are you laughing
about i'm like dude how can you set my
quota
how can you set a quota for me dude you
you don't even know your potential much
less mine because i'm the one that knew
what i could be doing i'm sitting there
quietly as a salesperson i could come in
two hours early i got nothing to do i
was single
i was lonely i had nothing to do i could
have gotten work two hours early i could
have stayed four hours later how can
somebody that doesn't know what's going
on for me set my potential you're
compromising location because of price
buy the best assets you can buy folks
i've been doing this 30 years i've
bought
what are we at right now 10 000 units
i'll be in 12 000 units by the end of
the year
i have bought and sold probably 15
thousand apartments four plus billion
dollars worth i'm sharing with you from
my heart these are the mistakes i made i
thought too small
number two
i
compromised location over a little bit
of money money is garbage okay the money
i have in my pocket
i mean let's face it it's not worth a
lot it buys goods and services it'll
trade at amazon you can't even go to
neiman marcus and drop the whole wad
anymore they won't take they won't take
two thousand dollars in cash they want
to put it on a credit card probably
their credit card okay so you got to
keep a lot of cash today
here's some more cash
what could happen to this cash somebody
could steal it it could get burned it
could get lost it could get misplaced
you can't misplace a great location a
great location where there's starbucks
and old foods and maybe a chipotle and
there's traffic and there's jobs you can
never ever
too much
for a great location if you learn to
love the thing you hate you might find a
big gift in it and for me i didn't like
sales i hated it i tried selling when i
was 17 years old
lost a job
18 i tried again part time during the
summer lost the job
19 years old lost the job i had had five
experiences in sales and hated every one
of them all different industries i just
kept moving industries thinking okay
it'll be different
this will be easy to sell i hated sales
i hated talking to people i particularly
hated the beginning the rapport building
you know i'm not good at breaking ice
like ron secco he can talk to anybody
i can't do that
i can't go into a room um
i could speak to 35 000 people but i
can't go into a room and start warming
it up
uh it's just i'm uncomfortable so
the point i'm trying to make is when i
was 25 the only job i could get was a
sales job and i said hey you gotta
decide that you're gonna get good at
this even if you hate it yeah because
you can't lose another job it would have
been my sixth firing and i'm like i
cannot lose another job i did by the way
get fired from that place but they never
got rid of me because i kept selling
yeah so every time they'd fire me i'd be
i'd go back and sell something they'd be
like okay
stay another day until the next time you
mess up something so
you know i went from hating sales
to committing to it to becoming now
known as like one of the greatest living
sales people on the planet
so
in the things you hate yeah like where
does the hate come from like the things
that you hate
the things that just grind you out like
you're gonna just bug you there's
probably if you just stay with it and
look just move to the side a little bit
and look behind it there might be some
great number one biggest mistake in real
estate is thinking too small
i know this is hard to think about but
uh i got a friend right now he's
actually letting me use this plane today
to fly to see the world series first
game astros vs atlanta blades
let's go astros okay i hope that doesn't
turn you off but but this guy that owns
this plane by the way
is a big real estate guy massive real
estate holdings okay that allows him to
to literally buy something this big this
is a gulfstream 650 what is this 65
million 70 million dollars
yeah and my plane just got sold
i'm waiting for another plane to come as
we take off here okay this is gonna be
big man this is gonna be a big takeoff
okay
oh my god
i think they already got that first
wheel up okay
and uh
i was on my way to houston for the world
series
look at this look at this take off
beautiful beautiful
and
i was booked on american airlines 500 to
fly to houston 500 bucks back
and this guy called us up and said hey
grant i don't want you flying on america
use my plane i know you're waiting on
yours just take my bird
and
and we'll figure it out later so uh
super nice to him but the point of that
story is one is who do you know and
number two how many people do you know
in real estate that are successful in
real estate because people that are
successful in real estate not just for
the last decade but for the last
thousand years
uh have been some of the wealthiest
people on planet earth it's a secure
great investment so number one biggest
mistake you're looking at one unit you
ought to be looking at 30 units
it is easier to buy 30 units it's easier
to make money on 30 units it's easier to
sell 30 units it's easier to get a loan
on 30 units than it is on one and i know
some of you are going to disagree with
me i got all the haters i need out there
please don't pile on but they don't
understand that when you buy one unit
you're not getting in the real estate
game to buy one unit if one unit's good
30 is better 30 times better if one unit
is good and you can raise the rent 200
awesome and that's awesome but what if
you could raise the rent 30 times
200 on 30 units just do the math if you
raise the rent 200 because real estate's
about making money it's about protecting
your capital it's about cash flow it's
about tax write-offs but if you can buy
one unit ultimately it's about making
money and you raise the rent 200 you're
making 200 extra a month
if you could do that 30 times you're
making 6 000 a month 72 000 a year and
that's when the game gets really really
super fun successful people are not
seeking money they're seeking freedom
[Music]
i'm talking about the top of the food
chain you guys should be studying the
top of the food chain you should not be
studying your buddies
study the top of the food chain they are
available for study read everything
they've done if i read warren buffett i
take warren from the beginning to the
end and i read everything he's done i go
i go deep on one guy i don't study a
bunch of people in the beginning i'm
like is the dude about money no the guy
was about freedom what is freedom
freedom man i get to do what i want when
i want as long as i want
how i want i get to say what i want to
whoever i want and i get to cut a
customer out of my face if i want to how
many of you like to get rid of some of
your customers like
get out of my office
leave my office i don't want to do
business with you
okay i want i want to do business on my
terms
not your terms and not the marketplace's
terms and i don't want a competitor
pushing on me
i want to have enough flow coming in
that i get to say i don't want this
business anymore i want this business
everybody with me
okay that's freedom financial freedom is
not about money the wealthy get wealthy
not saving money they invest their money
you're never going to create wealth ever
it is impossible to create wealth
because you have a profession
or because you're great at your job or
career
the only way to create true wealth
true wealth
is through investing
it is not through learning it's not
through watching videos it is not by
going to conferences the number one best
most successful way probably the only
way to ever create real wealth
beyond millions of dollars by the way
is uh
quit saving
quit saving you money this is what my
parents did they saved money they didn't
invest their money correctly they didn't
take money leverage it into real
investments because they were terrified
of losing their money i understand that
but there are asset classes out there
where you can never lose your money many
of your buying assets without cash flow
flippers wholesalers developers
everything i've ever bought was
developed by someone else i've never
flipped and i've never wholesaled why
because i want to own that property that
great location and what can make sure i
own it keep it even through down cycles
cash flow
you've got to get the cash flow okay i
don't care if it's two percent three
percent or four percent five percent six
percent
i'd rather have a three percent cash
flow on a great location
than a six percent
cash flow on an average location what is
the the mindset you would share with
anyone who's 40 50 or 60 and b above who
hasn't
accomplished what they want yet
what would you say to them
based on what you've learned after 50.
you know i used to tell myself i would
never have anything to contribute to the
world until i was 50.
because i'm very immature i've always
been described as a rough diamond like
like rough around the edges
abrasive
not much of a filter you know i i am i
mean i know everything that people say
negative about me for every one thing
every the public has i i know i know
every one of them
there's nothing anybody ever says about
me that surprises me i'm like yeah i
know that
like you guys don't think i know that i
live with me every day late
i did actually did not think i would
have anything to contribute worthwhile
until i was 50 years old and uh that was
about the time the economic uh collapse
was the great recession and i was so
lost in that financially i didn't
understand i was actually being farmed
right there i was being matured i was
being prepared for what whatever's going
on in my life right now
uh really the the creation of grant
cardone has happened in the last 10 or
12 years not
not before that
the grant cardone people know today is
being being developed right now and i
would just tell people that are older
like
dude you're going to have more energy
later unless you don't
you're going to have more genius later
unless you refuse to
you're going to have the ability to
influence more unless you refuse to
influence
and age has got nothing to do with the
game like nobody really knows my age
like
uh i was 50 years old when i was in
pueblo
i told everybody i'm 50 years old my
name's louis curtis i have two kids
beautiful two kids i got a wife named
ava
had made up names for the kids i had to
make up all that story
and we live in l.a and i hate it
um because if i told people i was me in
miami
if anybody went and searched it
and started doing you know images like
people do all that stuff today
i know
so um i would just tell people man you
look i look at people that are 80 years
old i'm like dude i got 20 years left
you know how much damage i could do in
20 years i know guys are in great shape
uh dolly parton i mean she's still
hammering she never did nine to five
she made some money on a song called
nine to five
you know but she's been doing five to
nine for for years so i just think
people can get better if they want to or
they can get worse you're either going
to decay
are you going to reboot yourself over
and over again i have i have a couple
businesses this year we'll do 150
million dollars
my real estate we have 2.5 billion worth
of real estate that we own that produces
cash flow almost 10 000 units that that
2 200 bucks a month do the math on that
things are very good at our place
and i'm like
why don't you become a real estate agent
okay average real estate agent makes
what 25 000 bucks a year or something
25 000 a year okay right something like
that
it's sad
it's sad and i want to talk to you about
the finances right now okay
somebody said about not chasing
squirrels i think she was talking about
chasing other opportunities is that
right okay but also you guys need to
think about not chasing squirrels that
don't get your opportunity here because
they're squirrels they're gathering nuts
like oh i can't i can't i don't want to
put signs up i'm like dude move on
you need people i need people in my life
that are heavily financially motivated
i hear everybody talking about their
wives and their kids and and oh my god
life is to be lived you cannot live on
this planet without money folks
okay nowhere can you go and buy
something the yacht
the experience the weekend i would look
for people that are financially
motivated that want to make more money
and that understand that financial
illiteracy is what's hanging people up
from their dreams
you got people hey what do you want to
do well i want my time off what are you
going to do with time off you ain't got
any money
the hell man you want to you want to
know the cause of depression
too much time and too little money
get me a job get me a mission get me
something to do give me possibility give
me a payoff what do you look for when
you're making a real estate investment
if it's anywhere in the world or yeah
yeah what are the key things that i look
for cash flow fresh number one i look
for cash flow because cash flow will
allow me to keep a piece of property
first through the cycles
so number one i want to be paid for
something i do not speculate on real
estate i've never lost a penny investing
in real estate i've been doing this for
35 years
uh number one i want cash flow number
two i want a great location that's
irreplaceable i care less about the
kitchens and the living rooms
and the exterior the paint the roof i
care nothing about those all those
things can be changed the location can
never be changed and the third thing i
want to know when i buy a piece of real
estate is
who can i sell this to
exactly okay so i should know who i'm
exiting with i should literally know who
the next buyer will be before i purchase
the property 2008 2009 was tough for you
just like it was for a lot of people
what was the lesson you learned then
that prepared you for 2020
that you when the recession hit you said
okay i know exactly what to do based on
that pain in 2008. yeah well i was so
disappointed with myself then like
i had not put my family in a position to
to
flourish and prosper
because of suppression you know the tide
goes out you don't have a boat shame on
you right and i didn't have a boat dude
i mean i had i looked good i looked good
until it happened you got a suit you had
the car i thought i was good i thought i
was good but i was too small small small
always gets hurt
and that that was my big wake-up call in
2008 i didn't have enough assets i
didn't have enough money i my business
was too small my customer base was too
small uh i was too relying on too few
verticals this was the creation of 10x i
blamed no one in 2008 9 and 10. i was
like okay i'm in
i got myself in [ __ ]
this is not about the mortgage crisis
it's not about the builders it's not
about the strippers they got 17 loans
this is about me i was in this palace i
was in this fear i was i let my family
and myself down
nothing was happening to me
and the most important thing is
i was not in a position to take
advantage of it that's the thing that
pissed me off
and so i told elena i said the next time
this happens
dude we're going to freaking rock and
then covid it happened and covid i was
shooting a tv show and my company would
have the best years i've ever had
wow i wasn't even here
we we bought more assets this year than
we bought the year before we raised more
money this year than the year before it
um you know when when when lehman
collapsed in 2008 i had 50 million
dollars worth of debt i told elaine i
said the next time the [ __ ] hits the fan
i might have a billion dollars worth of
debt i know i told i i said i'm gonna
have a half a billion dollars worth of
debt we had a 1.2 billion dollars worth
of debt when covid hit i made a launch
out i was in a middle class family
raised by a single mother we had a roof
over our head three meals a day
i had all the love i could do but god we
had no money
and when you don't have money you have
fear
when you don't have the right vehicle
when you're in a vehicle you're you're
working real estate and the most you can
make is three percent and they're going
to chop you you know they're gonna chop
you you know the seller's gonna
cut you up three percent you got me two
million over asking
and you want three six percent and i
gotta split it with my wife
right
how many of you get chopped up
you're getting chopped up because you're
not professional enough yet
when they're still asking for your fees
they are saying hey you are still not
the player that i that deserves a full
fee
so you got to change your game now man
particularly with inventory problems
that you have right now you're going to
continue to have this inventory problem
folks this is not going away housing
prices over the next decade will not go
down they will go up they will continue
to go up you're looking in a rear view
mirror thinking about what oh [ __ ] i
should have bought everything
because you should have by the way but
you didn't
because you didn't sell enough to have
enough to buy enough
right and you were sitting in the market
you were sitting in the market how many
times have you said this is a good deal
how many of you have said that before
this is a good deal
why don't you buy it
oh because you can't
because you didn't
so you didn't do enough to put yourself
in your family in a situation where you
could and that's what happened to me in
2010 i had not done enough i had three
successful businesses all three of them
got cut off because
of of this mortgage thing it took me a
long time to understand that i had
limiting beliefs especially when i was
doing well so when i started making 80
and 90 000 a year in sales this is many
many years ago that's like 270 000
today in an industry by the way where
the top producers were 40 000. the
limiting beliefs that i had at that time
and then even when i was making a
million dollars a year were the ones
when i was making money you know when
you're not making any money it's clear
you got a limiting belief you know
you're making 30 grand a year and that's
all you can make no matter how good you
are no matter how much you smile no
matter how much service you provide no
matter how early you get there how late
you stay and you still make 30. you know
there's a limiting belief because
everything would indicate you should be
paid more when you're making a million
dollars a year you start thinking i
don't have any limiting beliefs so the
way to handle that is you need to study
people that have created massive amounts
this is exactly what the 10x rule was
about create massive amounts in the
millionaire booklet talks about earning
money keeping money and multiplying
money this is what the great sales
people don't do i know great sales
people that have never figured out how
to multiply money i know sales people
that are so good like i'm like dude that
guy is probably a better sales person
than me but he's still broke he's broke
because he made his money didn't know
how to keep it
or he kept it didn't know how to
multiply it how much you earn is a
limited belief how you keep it where you
keep it is a limiting belief if you have
money in the bank or equity in your
house or you have a retirement account
you have a limiting belief about money
you're saving for a rainy day you have
equity in your home waiting to pay it
off in 30 years completely ridiculous no
no high performance person needs to
worry about paying their house off you
should rent where you live
own
stuff that other people pay you for okay
and just rent where you live and be
mobile and the third thing is you know
planning for having cash sit in an
account just sitting dead in an account
or in your wall or underneath your bed
or in your safe or the vault wherever it
is oh but what about an emergency if
your money's in the bank and the
internet goes down you won't be getting
your money out there's no getting the
money if you got it underneath your bed
what what for like some of you are
storing money in gold gold is a limiting
money belief you're like oh my god the
world's going to come to an end gold
will not help you out of the end of the
world scenarios you should make a whole
list of all the limiting beliefs that
you have around money number one number
two you should most importantly make a
list of limiting actions
not limiting beliefs because your
beliefs are turning into actions how you
save money how you spend money how you
invest money diversification is also a
limiting belief okay now i know a lot of
people recommend diversification
especially the people on wall street
that benefit from you diversifying the
most
they don't want you all eggs in one
basket but if you study the super
wealthy they took stakes once they got
super rich then they're like okay i'll
own the railroads the banks
and all the grocery stores what was the
first thing you ever sold when you were
a young young grandpa first thing that i
the young grant cardone the first thing
i ever sold was uh i think it was
clothes was it clothes yeah i think i
was selling i was in a clothing store
and i earned six percent on a tie okay
socks and t-shirts
um and at that time i think a tie cost
like i don't know maybe
20 bucks so i'd make like 12 cents or
something wow
i was bumped up about it too i was
actually excited i had minimum wage
minimum wage back then was like
1.85 and i'd get a little you know
70 cent
commission
right yeah what was your favorite that
great what was your first uh real estate
investment my first real estate
investment was a single family home it
was 78 thousand dollars i put three
thousand dollars down i thought it was a
genius move
i used three thousand to buy seventy
eight thousand dollars i i thought okay
this is the best thing i i don't even
see how this can be
and uh you know that today would
probably here because it's 20 down now
would probably cost me 15 000 but that's
still a good deal 15 000 i could
leverage a 80 000 piece of real estate
obviously you can't buy anything here
for 80 000
um more like a million dollars maybe out
in the country yeah yeah but not in the
city you're looking
you know millions around yeah but but
but if you could figure out just if you
could just make the transition the
biggest mistake i made in real estate
was i didn't buy enough real estate i
should have bought more real estate i
should have bought it more aggressively
i should have paid more i should have
bought in better locations
because i was thinking too small i was
thinking about the three thousand
dollars i had rather than how could i go
raise the money yeah so look there's no
shortage of money there's a there's a
sharda crate a shortage of creativity
and commitment but there's no shortage
of money so
you know you got million dollar
properties here how can i go get
gather some family members and some
friends put 200 grand together and own a
piece of real estate that we know is
going to be worth more money in the
future consumer debt is terrible debt
suicide debt that's that's credit card
debt lamborghini buying the lamborghini
on debt uh like if you're going to buy a
lamborghini at lease it for 24 months if
you can't afford the 24 months you can't
afford the lambo debt for clothes
christmas gifts
i mean it's stupid it's stupid to borrow
money for for for this santa claus for
your kids i know i know people are going
to hate that message that's why there's
so many people dislike you know they
just don't like it it's stupid to go in
debt if you want to do it and uh and for
for fun or for whatever then that's okay
but you mean you're not investing in
a potential greater future no
now if i if i borrow money for santa
claus that's one thing if i borrow money
for
to to invest to
to buy to invest in in a piece of real
estate for my kids you know i mean i
know which one's going to work yeah if
you just follow the tax write-offs
you'll know the right thing to do
i can't write off santa i can write out
the real estate
right so um
yeah bad debt is anything that i have to
then pay the interest rate on
good debt is i made an investment in my
consumer or my tenant is going to pay my
debt that's powerful so you're trying to
you're trying to get more debt you
probably have more debt with me than you
even know
like like because of the investments
you've made with me you have debt you
have good debt
you just don't really know it your
accountant does though because because
we're sending them the k1 at the end of
the year that's why when we send you a
check you don't pay income on that check
that's nice very nice
so you you look at your return but you
know whatever i paid you last year but
that is non-taxable income to you
because of the debt that we have because
of the debts
yeah exactly on the asset exactly three
parts to the real estate game number one
is the deal
i found me a good one right here i'm in
the heights one of the most desirable
neighborhoods in all of the 713
number ones the deal number two is the
debt you got to get a bank that's
willing to lend on that we're working on
that right now that market's insane
right now now and i'm still learning how
to play that game
making connections getting relationships
with people i've had money quoted to me
at three and three three and three
quarters
all the way down to 2.75
and then last night got some money
quoted to me at under two percent in
sane in the membrane changes everything
in the game when you get your debt right
the third part of the deal is cash
equity how much can you put down to buy
the deal so many of you out there would
be looking at deals this size if you
knew
how to get the debt and the equity but
because you you think you're short on
debt and equity
you reduce the deal size or the location
or the quality of the asset most of you
are chasing the debt the equity from the
treatment should be chasing the deal
because the right deal with the right
story in the right location the right
traffic the right printer
it'll always bring the money i'll tell
you a story i just did a deal in boca
raton i paid 70 million dollars for the
deal
and i knew like i moved on this deal so
fast it was unbelievable because i knew
that market right i didn't have to do a
lot of research because i'd already done
the research so i still did the research
right because i'd already done a
research you know what i'm saying i'm
gonna go check out this restaurant right
now see how they're doing and um
bought the deal closed the deal very
little due diligence by the way just
wham
looking for reasons to buy the deal
because i knew the location we raised
the rents
500 a month already i've been in 60 days
we just had one maybe two rent two rent
leases come in at a thousand dollars
more
than they were before we bought them and
we got great plans for the property
we're gonna do great stuff for the
tenants there
point is
when you raise the rents man guess what
you make the property better you have
more money to take care of your tenants
it improves the value of the property
and gives you some momentum in that
property
uh
and then momentum to buy more deals
point is
dude find the right deal in the right
location at the right time and the right
price the debt and the equity
i call the lender today he's like i paid
69 million they're like we'll give you
60 million dollars for the debt on that
deal based on its performance just in
the last 60 days since you took
ownership
that is
unbelievable that means i only need nine
million dollars to buy the deal and i've
already raised 20. again uh know your
location
get some support around you uh real
estate is a team sport okay it's about
relationships about that's about
relationships equity is about
relationship deals without relationships
yeah so best advice i have received my
mom said hey invest in yourself you'll
never lose
i have reminded myself of that
many times workshops i go to uh
events that i attend where i'm going as
somebody to get educated okay books that
i've read i'm like it's not a waste of
time
even even if you don't think you learn
anything
it is not a waste of time you think you
think you haven't
that it was a waste of time or you
didn't learn anything because you hadn't
used it yet
you may use that piece of data one day
and so number one anything you invest in
time or or
or money in trying to improve yourself
you're not going to lose that the beauty
salon the restaurant the bar the bar
owner
the consultant we've all had the
experience of
resenting our customers starting not to
like them
and it's because we become dependent
upon them
we have too few if we're resenting our
customer what is that saying about us
that we're not building our brand that
we're not growing that we're not selling
enough yeah you didn't go you didn't you
didn't build the top of your funnel out
enough
because this this part of it's easy
even though you hate them they never pay
you money this is the kind of stuff that
goes on they don't pay me enough they
always complain they never use the
product no matter what i do for them
they [ __ ] and complain okay they're
never happy blah blah blah right
well the truth is those are indications
that you didn't build your your customer
base wide enough
because you now resent them your
resentment is an indication that you
rely on them too much
and every time they complain to you it
reminds you that i'm too reliant on too
little and and we've all done it we all
do it i've done it uh right now i'm
doing it in my real estate i told my guy
ryan the other day i said we're
depending on this one guy too much
and he's like why do you say that
because i'm starting to resent him
so what's the first thing we should do
what are the what's the action steps
after that when we resent our customers
you you got to you got to understand
it's not about them it's about you
has nothing to do with them you need to
go wide you need to go get more
customers
if you resent facebook if you if if
facebook pisses you off
it is because you are too
reliant on face a book you know it's
money's pretty simple too how do you get
it how do you keep it how do you
multiply it most people most people
spend their whole life just getting it
they never know how to keep it
um
i mean we don't even understand basic
stuff that currency is basically
uh comes from the word current where
something is moving you don't actually
get to
have own money you don't own the money
the money is gonna go some other place
and um so yeah it's unfortunate but
we're taught nothing on that subject how
do you
build wealth
and stay happy at the same time
well number one is i don't think you
know
money will not make you happy like if
you're not happy you're not happy so
it'll make you jubilant and it'll make
you giddy for a second you know if i
dropped off 100 million
you know at your feet right now uh it
would definitely change your attitude
for a bit
but sooner or
money and i'm gonna later be happier
i've never ever
i don't even know where this concept
came from
the the connection between the two
you know i go to the gym i think i'm
gonna build muscle
i go to the water fountain i think i'm
gonna quench a thirst i go to a football
game i think i'm going to be entertained
i get money i never think about okay i'm
going to get 10 million bucks
and i'm going to suddenly be happy
never i never even think about like that
i'm gonna get 10 million
and then i'm going to invest it and i'm
going to pick up 30 million on the next
swing and i'm going to take 30 million
and convert that to 90 million i'm going
to take that and convert it into 270 and
i'm going to get to you know blah blah
blah right and then what am i going to
do with it but
dude
i'm never thinking about it it's going
to make me happy your biggest expense in
business
if you got a talent or you got a
business your
biggest expense
is number one your taxes
[Music]
what the wealthy know is how to reduce
their tax bill that's what you don't
know that you got to get a handle on
reduce your tax bill to literally zero
and beyond that's right beyond that's
where you would get tax refunds or
credits going forward to reduce your
income
tax
federal and state to zero how do you do
that
i'm going to show
you anybody can do it it's completely
legal and if you don't do it come on
you're just not you're just not
following the tips of the wealthy i
didn't grow up with wealth
i grew up and had to figure out
[Music]
how to take my talent
increase my income reduce my tax bill
and then get
my money to work for me harder than i
work
for my damn money the goal is to take
your earnings reduce it to zero still
have the money
but take the money
and invest it
so let's say you're earning two million
dollars a year
if you live in new york city one million
dollars of that
is going to the irs that means you got
to figure out how to live on 1 million
dollars
and if you're a ball player out of that
came 200 grand for an agent another 200
grand probably for a manager and you're
having to live on 800 000 if you buy a
house for your mother you're freaking
broke again so i'm gonna show you how to
play the game you earn two million okay
live on as little of this money as you
can in the beginning do not spend earned
income don't spend it what you do is you
invest it and use it in a second
business and or real property so let's
say i take 200 million the state's gonna
take you're still gonna have your four
hundred thousand dollars go to agents
and managers
you got 1.6 million dollars i want you
to invest as much of that 1.6 million
dollars into real property
real property will buy you about 4.8
million dollars worth of in this case
real estate
at 4.8 million dollars worth of real
estate because it's got real property
4.8 million dollars for instance in a
deal that i'm doing right now will
provide you with 2.4 million dollars
worth of depreciation
that reduces this tax bill
of 1.6 after your managers these are
expenses
to negative 800
000 dollars that can be
see ya carry forward into future years
that means next year if you earn two
million dollars you're walking into that
year with an 800 000
credit against your income now you need
to check with your
tax attorney
you need to check with your accountant
you need to check with your manager and
your agent but i promise you all four of
them are going to tell you this guy's on
to something get your earned income
earned income
needs to be zero and passive income
i need to invest in a new whiteboard
your passive income of the
what do we say 1.6 million dollars that
we invested that we have left over we
literally i'm i'm encouraging your
littering no watches
no houses in the beginning okay don't
spend any money on the stuff no ferraris
take the 1.6 leverage it it'll about 4.8
million worth of real property
okay you want to stay focused on your
baseball your basketball your rapping
you want to focus on your business or
maybe you want to invest this money back
in your business and zero out okay you
want to reinvest in furniture equipment
uh if you're a musician into
equipment touring
anything to do with your business to
grow your business literally get your
earned income to be
zero the tax bill on zero is zero 61
percent of all
citizens in the united states last year
made
no contribution to the federal income
taxes
your job is to make sure that you take
your earned income because you got a lot
of talent
[Music]
reinvest that money okay so that you can
be better talent and or prepare for
transition when you no longer have that
talent so this 1.6 million dollars of
earned income after your agent
and your manager you would invest and
leverage three to four times
by 4.8 million dollars worth of real
estate that would give you 2.4 million
dollars worth of depreciation
in the first year it's a little
complicated now this is called
accelerated depreciation but this is the
game this is the game that the wealthy
know how to use and that's why they tend
to use
all their earned income okay some of the
biggest players in the world they pay
themselves zero one dollar a year i
think mark zuckerberg makes one dollar a
year but he gets stock options
real property
this 2.4 million dollars of depreciation
you get in 2021.
if you use it all you'll get it again in
22. if you don't use it all you'll get
it again in 2023 and you're going to
continue to do this every year okay i'm
going to continue to do the same
mechanism every year reinvesting earned
income okay so stay with me here okay
watch what's going to happen this 4.8
million dollars worth of real estate
remember this it's in the box
you own that that's your position okay
this 1.6 million dollars that you
invested should provide you with about
ninety thousand dollars a year in income
passive income okay that's in year one
if you do this again in year two it's
going to get you another 90 000 a year
in passive income that's 180 grand by
year two but in year two you now have
9.6 million dollars
worth of real estate real property that
should be appreciating in value
providing you and your family with
passive income now now we're at about
fifteen thousand dollars a month in
passive income and you're starting to
prepare third year fourth year fifth
year now you're at seventy five thousand
dollars a month in passive income you're
going to exit your career because
look you got five years maybe at max
ballplayers artists you don't have
forever you're not going to be a 35-year
baseball player a basketball player
so if you start multiplying these years
in year two i'm at 180 000 in year four
i'm at 360.
at year eight i'm at 700 grand in
passive income per year
and that is not counting the value of
the real property which in this case if
i can take this out eight years
if you could duplicate this every year
and not get a pay raise every year eight
years eight times if we did this every
year 4.8 million dollars
you've paid no taxes for eight years in
a perfect situation
and that would be 38 million four
hundred thousand dollars worth of real
estate
that is going up in value every year
this just goes up three percent a year i
could take this out and i say in the
next
10 to 15 years you'll have a hundred
million dollars worth of real estate
throwing out passive income most the
passive income is now
not taxed at the highest rates it's it's
somewhere as low as 19 a year where
you're paying 48 to 63 depending on
whether you live in la or new york one
of these crazy states happiness for me
comes from doing personally yeah yeah it
comes from accomplishing things
like i experience my happiness when when
i accomplish something i'm proud of
so when we do a conference and i walk
away
and i'm
thrilled at the event we put on the
quality the lights you know that feels
good you know when my the people around
me are happy when i look around when i'm
proud
of who i'm being and doing every day you
know that makes me happy seeing my kids
my kids are
i'm so proud of my kids they're such a
you know a validation that i'm a good
guy when i can't see the good guy in me
i can look at sabrina and scarlet say
hey you got to be a good guy to produce
those when i really started learning
from the
in the beginning what you learn is
you're learning from the master
you know and and so i'm i'm duplicating
and emulating then at some point you
cross over and you become the master
and and if if you're a guy like me i'm
always looking to improve everything i'm
looking for another little tweak another
little twist you and i did that with the
podcast i'm looking for that that next
thing all the time how to make something
just a little better
a little faster
and so at some point i kept studying
this guy until i i was able in the
beginning i didn't challenge anything i
used
i duplicated
i got let me tell the script that i that
i learned let me use exactly what he's
telling me to do do it
i whatever whatever i heard i'm gonna be
like i'm going to make that work
that's going to be my stable datum
and once i could re once i could trust
that then i could build on top of it i
never yeah budded anything oh i got a
better way in the beginning dude until i
got the results over and over consistent
results
then i started
then i started teaching it to other
people then i started learning angles
you kind of alluded to like your your
belief system your spirituality what is
that belief real quickly i mean like
just you know put it in the words yeah i
believe that i'm a spiritual being and
you know and and and i'm in a body and
and but but but i'm not a body i'm not a
brain i'm not a piece of meat i'm not
bones i'm not five eight i'm not 170
pounds
you know i'm i'm beyond time and and
energy and
measurable units
so i'm not i'm not really grant that's
my name that was given to my given to me
the these things that i've done the cars
that i drive
it's just stuff like the the the
undercover billionaire was extremely
spiritually liberating
adventure for me really i saw because i
lost everything i didn't have my money
didn't have the roles didn't have the
g63 didn't have the gulf stream
didn't have my name dude didn't have my
social media
you know didn't have my hair didn't have
my my goodies you know i didn't have 150
people on my team i didn't have
it was me
and i'm like damn dude like i don't need
anything yeah i'm in a new environment
when nobody knows me
and like it was so empowering because
i'm like i am truly
like i am capable taking care of myself
without money without credit cards
with just communication
you know
i think even in success some people luck
up right i mean the rights they don't
know they don't know i i 100 agree with
what you're saying
like they wonder can i do it again
there's that doubt
could i do it again
and you know when the when discovery
went to help me out a little bit like
because they're producing a shop like
let's keep it real it's
i'm like i don't want your help and
they're like no no we gotta we got a
meeting for you with so-and-so i don't
want it because for you to say about a
show throw it in the trash i don't want
it
and they're like well no they it's going
to be good tv i cannot take your help
and they're like wow we're trying to
help you i'm like yeah you understand
once i take your help i can't help me
once you help me then i become relying
on your help
tomorrow i'm gonna wake up and say can
you help me three days from now and be
like hey why aren't you helping me like
i become i become disabled money follows
attention when i get enough attention
money will follow it if i can get enough
people to listen to me somebody will say
hey i want to sponsor an ad because
there's so many people i just did a deal
this weekend it took like that long
because of my audience
i want to give this much money and i
want to give you options in my company
and i'm just going to cross my fingers
and hope good stuff happens
but he sees me interacting with all
these people and converting people right
so money follows attention if i can get
really bright over here money will go to
that
if it's a good cause if it's a bad cause
it's not gonna work okay but what
happens is
the the the the attention wanes
way if you can spike the money game the
money the attention will follow again
uh people pay a lot of money to be in
the super bowl or big soccer game right
because
there's a lot of people there so if you
could learn how about algorithms getting
eyeballs keeping eyeballs surveys
learning how to keep people's attention
man you're going to you're going to be
unbelievable and it won't matter how old
you are by the way michelangelo okay
michelangelo
he didn't want a pope but he didn't want
to paint this 16 chapel right dude the
the po the uh the pope said yeah i
understand you don't want to bruh start
painting
look what he did yeah yeah right so now
i don't know if that's you know i'm just
saying like
i know artists that do what they love
they can't even feed themselves
you know they they love their they love
their wife too or they love their
husband but dude you can't take care of
them you love your parents but you can't
take care of them so so it's it's just
not true if you just love something if
you only do the things you love there
might not even be any money in it
like you could love horses but
you should have lived like maybe 1400
years ago
yeah
and so falconry we had a falconry guy
out here yesterday teaching us about the
birds and the history of it two hours he
spent with us it was freaking
unbelievable
you know but
you know it's a very niche yeah right
yeah
you know 1400 years ago everybody had a
bird yeah you know that was your that
was the lamborghini of the day today
that's probably not
you could love it but you're not going
to feed your family with it you got to
commit first when you know something's
right folks commit
commit
go all in on the deal nobody knows what
you're what you're up to nobody knows
what's going on inside me i called my
mom that night and i said i met my wife
today and she's like
have you all been out where did y'all go
what did you do i said no she hates me
and she's like she hates you grant it
takes two and this is what i knew from
being in business and if you're taking
notes it might be worthwhile it does not
take two to tango
it does not take two to make a marriage
and it does not take a buyer and a
seller what it takes is you
it needs to be you first you have to
decide they're selling the house and you
got to decide that they're buying the
house before any house makes a
transaction i had to decide that she was
going to be the girl before she could
see that i was going to be the guy you
guys with me
all right 26 phone calls all of them
were light hey how you doing you know i
didn't mention that she never calls me
back
i didn't mention that she was breaking
my heart every time she didn't call me i
didn't mention the fact that her best
friend said i was too short
okay
you guys know what all your objections
are don't you like her a friend said
you're too short i said just tell me
what the real deal is i got to know what
the objection is i cannot handle the
unspoken objection what is the real deal
grant you're too sharp i said okay what
else what else you got uh you're not a
hollywood guy she's she's an actress i
wasn't in hollywood i'm not an actor
okay good what else you're a businessman
she thinks you're too conservative okay
what else what else you got well you
don't have a prison record
you don't have a prison record no
tattoos she like bad boys okay how many
ladies here like the bad boys
just be honest
okay be honest the lady over here is
like yes
i love them okay so so i just continue
to pursue her because like somebody said
earlier sometimes people change
how many of your room have changed
how many of you in the room have changed
exactly you're going to keep changing
too some of you're not going to like
so so
i pursued her until one day because i
know this okay and you might want to
keep this in your collection of
how you handle uh discouragement along
the way
when you get a no would you agree that
no is a version of yes
how many would agree with that
dude look i mean think about it what's
the opposite of yes
what's the opposite or no
what's in between
maybe
so i always tell people when they tell
me no i'm like don't say no
say maybe
okay just say maybe oh well maybe grant
maybe but not right now excellent
because i know no's can turn into yeses
i said no to a lot of things in life and
then done them you've walked into a
casino before i am not gambling tonight
i will not gamble you came down to cabo
i am not drinking while i'm here
okay you some of you came down no
enriched bread while i'm here
no chips no guacamole nothing okay and
as soon as you got down here you're just
like freaking hitting shots
eating guacamole slamming it in your
face right
so how do you get from no to
yes just show up in cabo
it's a maybe
right how do you get somebody to say go
go from not selling their house to yes i
will
get to a maybe
and then follow them up i actually
almost threw away what i had learned and
created this new thing called
information assisted selling information
assisted selling where i started leading
with what people wanted rather than
this guy kind of hid
it was the old school hide it don't
avoid the price bring it up later and
that's where i really started
accelerating everything giving people
the information up front allowing you to
understand how much this watcher ring
was or car was
before you even asked about it i'd tell
you it's 58 000. right away so you
wouldn't wait till the very end you'd
say yeah look look if you're if you're
shopping for a car or a watch or a ring
or a
coaching program whatever it is
you probably want to know how much it is
i know i would this this particular
product is 58 000 it would require about
you know 2500 down your payments would
be about 550 a month
um let's be sure you're on the right
product you see i've already i got the
va the value proposition the money i got
you thinking about money right now i
want you thinking about money so that
when i show the product
you can start making sense of it because
i can't convince you that it's worth it
you have to convince
yeah okay i can build value but you the
buyer is the buyer i can't be the buyer
i can only help the buyer make sense of
it i've somehow figured out
just over time there that i keep adding
these little companies
and i didn't know this it was just kind
of a mistake but all i was looking for
is i didn't want to depend on one flow
of anything okay this was the first
company this was me i was out selling
stuff picking up money
okay next thing i did was i i had a
partnership with a guy right here uh
called carter the cardone group it's in
orlando florida it's been a partnership
for 25 years guy paid me royalty to use
my name it was passive income i gave him
a majority of the company he sat there
for 25 years and went pumped his deal
used my material okay and then we
created a third company this was the
real estate
i started investing in real estate i
started buying real estate provided me
with a third flow of income
now what happened was i got fat right
here
and i got
uh
what's the word
complacent
like okay i'm good started playing golf
three times a week
everything's good um
you know
i'm doing great i'm alan
okay and and and then
and then and then and then and then 2010
came 2008 came like it just
took the little three circles
i didn't have the fourth circle the
fifth circle the sixth circle the
seventh circle i didn't have all these i
didn't have product lineups how many of
you have card on you here let me just
see your hand didn't exist that product
let me see your hand if you have card on
university okay beautiful man look at
the penetration
unbelievable like like you if you want
if you want customer retention get
saturation don't make people happy make
sure they buy your product
i'm not interested in making people
happy i'm interested having people on my
product
some people you can't make happy it's
impossible they're not happy people
all right so 2010 comes crushes me
i went back to selling
working on that business right there and
buying more real estate and then
creating more companies okay so that i
can start bringing good people in
you understand you got to you got to
keep expanding you cannot be dependent
upon one thing because that one thing
can go away everybody agree with that
one ad one promotion one person one
product
one of anything once you be the greatest
youtuber in the world the greatest
skateboarder in the world do like
something that's real don't be a liar
everybody's gonna know it and the higher
the food the higher up you go in the
food chain the harder it is to trick
people i don't know if i was 15 years
old today i'd be probably i'd probably
be teaching people
i'd first i'd go after the kid market
which really is a parent market
i talk to parents
and i'd probably create a youtube
channel about
uh how parents
how kids can
parents can get their kids to to learn
faster
and and you know
maybe come up with some tricks and hacks
and ebooks and courses to create a big
audience i don't know that i'd sell
anything in the beginning maybe i would
but
but i need to create a big audience so
then later someone either someone else
or myself can sell something to them
look if it doesn't include an audience
you don't have a business so i think the
first thing people need to do is figure
out how to create an audience hey it's
been said it's been said by people for
thousands of years
what you think if is what you get it
look behind me and you will see dreams
being made into reality
imagine that back here in london
uh i don't know a thousand years ago 800
years ago i don't actually know my
history that well
none of this existed somebody dreamed
about it somebody probably thought about
wow one day we'll have a village there
one day we'll have a city there
so today i want to talk to you about in
this
video i want to talk to you about your
dreams what you're thinking about what
are you imagining
i imagine i make up in my mind that
somebody thought about a little small
township not ever imagining that one day
there would be towers and glass and
steel and spheres and oh my gosh a city
with what 20 million people in it
literally where all the money in the
universe all the money on this planet
moves through this city the highly
successful people dream they imagine
they spend time literally writing out
what their future might look like now
i'm not talking about when i talk about
dreaming in this segment i'm not talking
about when you sleep and dream i'm not
talking about nightmares i'm not talking
about daydreaming
i'm talking about you envisioning
what your future might be like
when you see other people and you're
like god i wish i could do that or i
wish i could have that
other people if you speak about that out
loud they're they're going to try to
talk you out of it they're going to tell
you things like oh that's too much and
that's ridiculous i thought oh i'm going
to dream people are going to try to talk
me out of it because i had people trying
to talk me out of real estate
being on stage speaking in front of tens
of thousands of people running my own
events
creating millions hundreds of millions
of dollars in net worth i had people
trying to talk me out of that because i
thought that they were jealous or
envious or that they're like okay if
grant gets it i can't have it but the
truth is
most the people that are trying to talk
me out of my dreams and my
visualizations and me spending time on
actually imagining
what i could achieve
they weren't trying to talk me out of it
because they couldn't have it they were
trying to talk me out of it because they
quit okay it's crazy look it's not true
when somebody tells you you can't have
everything you want look at this look
behind me look at the ships look at the
water look at the river okay look at the
the commerce look at the monetization
that's happening back here the new
buildings that are being built the the
the glass and the steel and buildings
going up way higher than anybody ever
imagined possible
focus on your dreams the highly
successful people do this they think
about what is possible and then they get
themselves around other people that are
dreaming you can't just dream on your
own you got to get around other people
that actually allow your dream to
breathe and helps you with your
imagination you can't really paint
okay or create art in a vacuum you need
ideas you need to see what other people
are thinking and doing in order to
see what you could imagine or put down
on paper
look the fact is you're going to get
what you focus on you're getting it
right now whatever you have today
is what you focused on thought about in
your mind activated
in real life
and then reinforced on a daily basis if
you're in poverty today it's because you
probably grew up in poverty thought
about poverty think you're only poverty
think that you can only have poverty and
yes guess what that's what you had bill
gates said if you're born poor it's not
your fault if you stay poor yes it is
your fault that is see this is already
taking place in your life your your
dreams
if you take responsibility your dreams
if you're willing to take full
responsibility for what you have right
now
hey the fact is what you've been
dreaming
daydreaming night dreaming
work dreaming thinking about what you've
been talking about what you've been
focusing on throughout your 24 hour
period each day is what you're getting
look no person is happy without a goal
no person is going to be happy if
they're not working on being happy
people that have faith in the ability to
reach a goal
people that have faith in the ability to
win to reach a goal to hit a milestone
to achieve something those people are
happy so it's not just dreaming it's
like going to work every day and saying
hey i have a dream i have a goal i have
a target and i want to achieve that and
i'm going to do whatever it takes to
make sure i do achieve that
okay math and money math math and money
how old are you i'll be nine and three
days
nine and three days okay math and money
so
i'm gonna give you adding
subtracting you know how to do both of
those right yes
and i'm gonna do multiplying oh god
okay now which of these three are the
most important
i think when it comes to money when it
comes to money
let me show you one plus one
over two two plus one equals what three
okay good two minus one equals
what one so we got three one
two
times
three equals one
wait that's simple um two times three
yes okay so which one of these is the
most powerful when it comes to mine i
think multiplier yes why would that be
because if you have
if you know how to multiply right and
you have a dollar right yeah and you can
you're able to multiply that into two
dollars and you can multiply that two
dollars into 800 million thousands
we could get there faster right okay so
watch i'm gonna give you a little i'm
gonna give you a little drill here to
show you the power of multiplying add
subtract
multiply okay we're gonna use the same
numbers every time two plus two two plus
two two minus two two minus two one oh
wait that's zero
okay that's four
zero two plus two is four
two minus two is zero and two times two
two times two
it's four let's do this let's do this
we're gonna do another because we love
tens right okay we're gonna take the
number 10 because i have it on my hat
10x hey wait no now you have the number
10 on your hat okay 10 and we're gonna
do 10 plus
10
10 minus 10
and 10 times 10. 100.
so so watch 10 plus 10 is how much 10
plus 10 is 20. 20. 10 minus 10 zero
10 times 10 100. now we're using the
same numbers but notice the multiplier
the number gets bigger a lot faster than
the other two yeah
so what'd you learn from this exercise
yeah we need to that if you subtracting
doesn't help you subtract no you gotta
just get it okay okay no no subtraction
no reason to learn this in school kids
tests you know what you know when people
subtract stuff what they're doing is
they're like okay i'm gonna go to the
store i'm gonna spend this i'm gonna
budget my money they're using
subtracting to determine how much money
they can spend if you add it's obviously
going to be less than multiplying
because multiplying you're timesing the
number so then it's obviously more
because like 10
plus 2 is gonna be 12. 12. but
10 times 2. 10 times 2 is going to be 20
so multiplying half much faster
you're amazing okay so when it comes to
money you want to add subtract or
multiply you want to multiply mainly and
then use the other two for pesky things
like this like stuff that's not needed
you're awesome buddy okay so now what i
have to do is i got to figure out how to
go multiply my friends and my money so i
can get beyonce to come to the tennis
book yes
friends
you can multiply friends
so rather than adding one friend you
could add 10. multiply
multiply my friends multiply my money
good multiply my influence
united spelled influence no i'm just
going to write i n i n f
l
u
e
n
and help more people
because if i can maybe maybe i can help
beyonce or dolly parton or
who else uh adriana or her name is i
don't
know
ariana sorry just remember her by the
ponytail okay maybe reiny heine can get
ariana
you like ronnie
okay all right so okay if i can't get
beyonce and i can't get adele
and i can't get
i think jimmy fallon will do it i can't
get
ariana ariana okay and i can't get who
else did you want jolly party partner
jimmy fallon jimmy fallon who else who
knows kevin hart kevin hart
i can get kevin you can get kevin i
believe in kevin
i already had kevin i know i want kevin
again you want kevin again you love
kevin huh kevin's cool um who is he's
almost
who else
i'm sorry kevin okay who else you want
um what about the rock
yes the rock okay what about jimmy
fallon can bring ariana grande okay um
i either want beyonce or adele okay one
of the other not both of them together i
mean yeah you can choose i mean i'll
okay i'll tell you what i'm going to
invite one of those people or more
okay
but i need some huh
and kevin hart you want kevin hart again
i really had shorty
but look now we're best friends yeah
you know who joe rogan is i want zac
efron oh zach you want zac efron okay
all right well you did your math class
so yeah i'm gonna see what i can do
one or two of these people okay okay
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want some amazing
warren buffett motivation check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there look for the job that
you would take if you didn't need a job
i mean you know don't sleepwalk through
life and don't don't say it's all going
to be great you know i'll do this and
i'll do that and you know i'm just
marking time to get to be over